This is Jocko podcast number
one 16 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good evening. Good evening.
So this then was the culmination to die.
Die in the stinking mud
twice before I crossed this,
no man's land darting from
shell hole to shell hole.
I'm no hero.
I was numb with fear.
But this time a barrage was on.
I laid there at the
wastelands edge thinking
was there any way
to the right lay crack shot?
Snipers.
Yeah,
to the left in the brush machine.
Guns
hungry,
waiting
and fair in the front.
Great.
Bursting mud clouds
playing toss with bodies.
Yeah.
Get through once more sun.
The colonel had said communications down
our guns firing short killing our boys.
Yes it must be done.
But how?
Wait
the barrage sweeping across the field
and back a deadly windshield wiper were I
to follow it down. And when
I returned, dig in, I might
now
drunk with fighting fear.
I chased the mud cloud down the field,
kicking dead bodies,
twisting like a ghost.
And I laughed and I yelled,
you bastards. You can't get me
our trenches ahead.
Almost there.
Okay.
Back came hell's windshield
wiper, vomiting, death,
and I dug in,
dug in with all I had
mom, dear God, help me
on it. Came 40 feet,
20 feet.
God,
my head
torn from my body
is this what being dead is like?
Peace,
quiet,
clean,
white sheets.
My head must still be,
it hurts me.
These must be my fingers.
I can move them
and now a voice.
My boy
for you,
the war is over.
You hear that mom?
Okay,
I'm still alive.
I did not die.
I'm coming home
and that is
a poem
that was written by a man
by the name of Ralph Moan
of east main,
who left his job as a civil
engineer in Waterville,
Maine to enlist in the army in 1917
okay.
Then he was wounded badly on that day,
but he did live
and he was decorated for his actions on
that day in the citation for his award
reads the president of the United
States of America authorized by act of
Congress nine July,
1918 takes pleasure in presenting the
distinguished service cross to mechanic
Ralph t Moen,
United States army for extraordinary
heroism in action while serving with
company K hundred and
Third Infantry Regiment.
26 division American Expeditionary
Force near Rayville France 26 September,
mechanic Ramon,
who is detailed as a runner,
made several trips carrying
important messages across terrain,
swept by constant fire from machine guns,
snipers,
trench mortars and artillery.
His disregard for personal safety and
devotion to duty in the prompt delivery of
messages contributed greatly
to the success of the action.
Okay.
And Ralph Moan,
according to his family,
never spoke of the war to his
children or his grandchildren.
Okay.
But he did live with it
every day.
And tonight I am honored to have a guest
back on the podcast who is also wounded
in war,
but who has not let
that stop him in any way
from driving on with his mission and
his life and doing more than most people
could ever even imagine.
Mr Rob Jones,
a marine,
a wounded warrior,
and an inspiration to anyone that's a
lucky enough to come into contact with
him. Rob Jones, welcome back to the show.
Hey,
you know what?
It's an honor to be just a single time
guest on what I consider to be the best
podcast on the airwaves, but to be a
two time guests, purely rarefied air.
And I'm just appreciate you
guys deem me worthy of a,
of a second visit.
So,
and to be compared to that
gentleman is even greater honor. So,
yeah.
You know,
I read that a while back and it was one
of those things as I was reading it,
I was thinking, I was thinking about
you. I was thinking about, you know,
I was thinking about Jodi,
uh, thinking about Travis,
think about you guys that
were wounded bad and,
and I've heard that before.
It another is another book I read about
World War One where guys, they wake up,
they think they're in heaven because
they see white sheets and they see you,
there's a nurse there that's talking
nicely to them and they think their dad,
they think they're in heaven. And
that, that reminded me, you know,
when I read that I was thinking about you
and, and, and having waken up, you know,
in a, in a hospital somewhere.
And I know you actually woke up.
You're not supposed to wake up in Germany,
but you did.
No, you're not supposed to. But uh,
yeah, for whatever reason I woke up,
I think I need to drink a water.
So you need to hydrate. Yeah.
I'm not sure why I woke up. I
don't remember much, but, and uh,
I didn't definitely didn't see anybody
you could mistake for an angel or in this
smelled squad leader.
She's not an angel.
Well for anyone that's listening that
hasn't listened to the first time rob was
on,
go back and listen to episode 92 and
that's where we go through what rob went
through, how he's raised,
you know, growing up,
joining the Marine Corps deployment
to Iraq, deployment to Afghanistan.
And that's, that's where rob
was wounded, hit an IED and,
and ended up losing both legs
above the knee. But like I said,
that didn't stop rob.
And he went from that.
And in the podcast we,
we jumped really quickly through Sorta
your healing process and we jumped right
into the fact that you
were, went out, did the,
the Paralympics as a rower and we jumped
into the fact that you rode a bicycle
across America,
which is yeah.
Across America during the
polar vortex, by the way. Yeah.
That's all that stuff hasn't
covered in 92 but I was,
I was actually going back and I was
listening to [inaudible] 92 and I realized
that, you know, maybe it's just your,
it's your attitude that might've
might've made me kind of do this in the
conversation. Your attitude is like, yeah,
I lost both my legs and then I was just
competing in the Paralympics. You know,
you, you, you made it sound like it's
like it was like, it was easy. That's,
that's the way it kind of came
across in the podcast. And, and what,
what I wanted to do today was kind of at
least go back and talk a little with a
little bit more detail
about that process of going,
cause it's a long process, right? Year
and a half year for me anyway. Yeah. Yeah.
A year and a half of,
from letting the wounds heal
all the way through. You know,
where now you're,
you're competing in the Paralympics and
you're getting around in your mobile and
all that.
So you get back.
How long does it take for your wounds
because you can't do anything until your
wounds are healed up,
right?
No, I mean, well you can do some stuff.
You can't do anything as far as
prosthetics are confirmed, are concerned.
So in the beginning, you know, the,
the physical therapist would come in and
they just basically just had me move my
stumps around. And that
would be like, you know,
lift your right stump 10
times if your left one,
move it out and back and then that
would be it for the day or you know,
I could do, you know, my arms still works.
So I would do a little pull ups on my
little trapeze bar that I had attached to
the, uh, the bed. But
yeah, it was, you know,
surgeries every other day
they just come in and uh,
take me over and they would just be
this cleaning the wound out and he dead
tissue or anything that was still
left in there. They cleaned that out.
But I had these wound vac machines on
that we're just constantly sucking the
fluids out of the wounds
because they were,
they were open for the
first month and yeah,
so they're just like kind of suck in that
stuff out and it's just a waiting game
at that point.
I mean you're,
you can do some stuff like I've
figured out how to, you know,
it's slowly got to kind of furry,
figured out how to move my body around
and moved my legs around and get
comfortable.
And
were you getting like the phantom pains?
Yeah, I didn't get it as bad as Travis
had it. I never had to do, uh, uh,
what was it, a ketamine coma
in order. I had it som, um,
and they gave me this stuff called Lyrica,
which is like a fibromyalgia
medication and I got it.
And I never really had it all that bad.
It's like,
it's pretty much at the
same level. It is, is,
is now where every maybe twice a day.
My toe will kind of like hurt pretty bad
for four or five seconds and that's it.
But there's some people
that have it a lot worse,
so I kind of lucked out with
that. But yeah, so first month,
this kind of learning how to get into
the wheelchair. Um, and you know,
at first I wouldn't, I couldn't, I was
so sore I couldn't really move very much.
And so I haven't have to have a nurse.
And whoever was in there visiting me,
if I wanted to get my wheelchair, I'd be
sitting on this little pad and I'd say,
all right, well I want to go for
a role. And then so they would,
the nurse would be on one side and the
other person will be on the inside and
they kind of like scoot me onto the
wheelchair and then we'd have to take the
wound vac machines and hook them onto
the wheelchair and take my catheter,
which I was very,
very protective of that Catheter Jack,
hang that on there. And then, uh, the
Ivy Paul would have to come with me.
And so then I would just kind of roll
myself around the ward a couple times
with, you know, my dad or my mom
or somebody pushing the IV pole.
And Yeah, just do that a couple times.
Then I'd go see my buddy Daniel,
because he couldn't get out of bed yet.
So I go and see,
visit him for a little bit
and I go back to my room.
And that'd be pretty much my exercise
for the day and then have a like six
milkshakes.
This a eaten as much as I possibly could
to, to help with the healing process.
Yeah.
Where did you go through
the whole woe is me,
why did this happen to me? Did
you go through that at all? And I,
I mean,
I know I've,
I've listened some of your stuff and
reading some of your stuff, you know,
you talk about the fact that you knew you
had to just move to like an acceptance
phase right immediately. Is that,
is that what you did? I mean,
how did you get,
look man,
people hate all kinds of
freaking roadblocks in life and,
and very few of them are as heavy of and
big of a roadblock as you hit and you
seem to power through that thing.
Like miraculously,
you know, I don't, I never,
I never actually entered into an extended
period that can be described as like a
depression or woe is me or you know,
feeling sorry for myself.
It would come in very short waves,
um,
where, you know, I'd be,
I'd be sitting around or I would
struggle with something maybe.
And then after I figured it out,
I might sit there for a couple
of minutes and be like, man, uh,
but that'd be about it. And then we'd be
go away after, you know, a minute or two,
it'd be kind of like,
uh,
I
almost kind of like,
if you're,
if you're talking to a girl in a bar
and you like your voice cracked and he's
just totally blow it and you look like an
idiot and then you go back to the tape,
we were like, man, he like that. It was,
it was almost kind of like that
or just like, man, how did I,
how did I miss that IED?
You know, man, this sucks.
But, and I, you know, I
didn't really think about it
probably this way at the time.
I couldn't articulate it at the
time like this, but it's like
that.
Whether or not, you know, I
deserved, I, I, you know, I did,
I could acknowledge I didn't deserve it.
I didn't deserve to be a double ibt.
I didn't, uh, it wasn't, you know, fair.
There's a lot of other guys that were
running around in that same exact area.
They didn't step on it, so it wasn't
necessarily fair that I had to be in, uh,
nfpt I didn't want to be an amputee,
but
none of that mattered.
Um,
it did none of that had any bearing
on whether or not I want it to have an
enjoyable life. And I did. I
sat there and I was like, well,
what is my mission in life?
If you really take it to its base
level, you know, have an impact,
uh,
enjoy my life.
That doesn't change just because now I'm
an amputee and whether or not it's fair
or the fact that I'm starting from a,
you know,
a little bit more of a disadvantaged
position now all that stuff has no bearing
on whether or not I want
to accomplish my mission.
And so realizing that you just kind
of, well, what do I have to do now?
That stuff's in the past.
So all I can really affect
is how I react to it.
And you know, so I think that's kind
of how I, I skipped all that stuff.
Did you, I know, um, one,
one thing that I remember,
and you know, one of my
guys, Ryan job, he got,
he got shot in the face and he got
gravely wounded and you know, he,
he ended up blind and um,
he was down with a lot of casualties
that had guys that had really bad brain
injuries and he was there for
a little while and you know,
these were guys that had been
severely wounded and like I said,
had severe brain injuries.
So they're having trouble communicating,
they're having trouble
with motor skills and,
and these are almost all the time
come with other physical injuries.
And you know, his attitude was, hey, look,
I'm taking up a bed here and we
should give it to someone else.
These guys are having a
much harder time than me.
I'm lucky because I
didn't get that injury.
All I got was blind and
you know, some, some,
some damage to my face.
But it was,
it was amazing to me to see
a guy like Ryan job who,
who just looked at him itself and said,
I'm lucky.
I'm lucky those guys
are worse off than me.
Try and give your efforts to take care
of these other guys instead of trying to
take care of me. I can, I can do, okay,
open up this bed for someone else to
send me to, uh, send me somewhere else.
And that's what they did. And I think
that, you know, that attitude of like,
Hey, this could be much worse. Right. And,
uh, to me, first of all,
hearing him talk about that was,
was a testament to like the spirit of a
guy that just is going to carry on and
drive on and the things that he
did before he died or was amazing.
You know, he graduated college
with like, with like a straight,
a grade point average. He
got married, he, you know,
his wife got pregnant. His, uh,
he got a job with a defense contractor
and he was like totally on the path and
crushing yet despite the fact
that he had, uh, you know,
one of the best excuses
someone could have, hey,
I got wounded and I lost my vision. It
didn't, it didn't slow him down at all.
He climbed Mt. Rainier. He just
did amazing things. And the,
his attitude of, look, I'm
in a bad place. Not that bad.
I'm going to push on. And like
you said, this isn't gonna,
this isn't going to stop me from
having a great life and, and,
and getting after it basically. Yeah. So
couple of things. Uh, I'm glad
you brought that up because it,
there's definitely something to my own
recovery during the time where I got
there. So it's kind of like, I
almost had a feedback loop on myself,
so I got,
I was immediately thinking about,
even in the blast credo is one
of my first thoughts was like,
my mom's going to be pretty upset about
this. And when I woke up in Jeremy,
the one thing that I did was
I asked for a stupid hat.
I was like, Oh, my squad
leaders there. I said,
see if you can find us a stupid luck and
a hat that I can wear when I come out
of the ambulance. So that when my
mom sees me for the first time,
she'll see this stupid hat and maybe it'll
make her laugh a little bit, you know?
Um, but, you know, obviously
they didn't find one.
And,
um,
but I think what happened was I had a
good attitude in the first week or two and
then that kind of set a precedent for
myself and all my friends that came in,
all my family that came in saw me with
that solid positive attitude and that,
you know,
that gave them hope at the same time.
So they had that hope and then I kind of
went on and there was times, you know,
they saw me already like that.
So if there was ever a time where I
was feeling sorry for myself or anything
like that, I was like, you know what,
my mom, my dad, all these people
have already seen me being positive.
And if I flip that around then
that's going to hurt them now.
And so I have to keep that in mind.
So when I'm, it's not really about,
well it's not only about me.
So that forced my,
that's forced me to make sure I maintain
my positive attitude because you know,
they're depending on me,
I'm depending on them at the same time.
So they're depending on me to stay
positive so that they can stay positive.
And so it kind of, we kind of fed
off each other. And so, you know,
that just kind of snowballed I
guess until, you know, here we are.
Now you get so, so you're talking
like a month of milkshakes.
They weren't mint chocolate chip,
but they were good. You know,
and you're just feeding yourself. You're,
you're trying to, trying to heal up,
get the wounds to actually heal. And
you're, every time you go around,
every time you leave your bed, it's a
gut check because you got to, you know,
do the,
the,
the wound draining and
all that other stuff.
And then after a month,
things are starting to heal
up. At what point did you,
were you able to like get yourself out,
get yourself in the wheelchair?
I think I was probably after that first.
So I was, I spent a week in the ICU,
uh, you know, high on morphine. I don't
remember much from that, that time period.
And then I get to the ward and
probably after that first week,
maybe 10 days on the main
ward, I'd be like, all right,
I'm going to try and do this myself guys.
And then it took five times the
length of time, but I did it.
And then from then on I
was doing it on my own.
And so, yeah, that,
and that was kind of the
biggest milestone for, you know,
being in the hospital that
during that healing period, uh,
was being able to do that. And
then so and then, you know,
as they slowly took tubes away.
Um,
and then the final milestone for being
in the hospital at that point was when my
wounds were finally sutured
closed and I got the skin graft,
I'd take a skin graft from my left leg
and put it on the inside of my right
thigh. And once they did that and that
was the healed that they checked it out,
made sure it was good, then I was ready
to be transferred over to a Walter Reed,
but I still had stitches, a all in
my or staples, staples or stitches,
one of the two.
And so after that was done, that's when
they transferred me over to Walter Reed.
And even then I still had to wait for
those stitches to come out before I could
get fitted for prosthetics.
And I was probably in the inpatient in
the hospital for another two weeks while
I waited for a room to open
up in the outpatient housing.
So it was pretty similar in those first
two weeks. I just had the IV line.
That's all I had. And
you know, I could go out,
are they pumping you with antibiotics
the whole time or what do they,
what do they got?
An Ivy and euphoria,
um, pain medication. Um,
and I think it's probably just a stand
at the just in case something goes wrong.
They can, they have quick
access. Uh, my buddy Daniel,
he had a picc line to like straight
into his heart. What's that? It's just,
I think it's just a, a tube. They just
put it straight, put it into your chest.
And I guess maybe it's just for
quicker access for pain medication.
So I'd be in the hospital that
first month and you know, the,
they gave you the pain button so you can
kind of control it yourself and to be
funny because they, they, it only
meters out so much in an hour.
You can hit it like once every
five minutes or something.
But in the first week I'd be
kind of passing out and I,
whenever I woke up I'd hit it a couple
times just to make sure I get in that
dosage because I was scared. Like, what
happens if this pain button goes away?
Like I don't want to face that.
And so they'd come in after an
hour and the nurses say, you know,
you can only hit this thing when we
went every five minutes. Like yeah,
yeah I know. I said, well you've
hit it like $200 the last hour.
Like oh well you know, I just hit
it just, you know, I fall asleep.
Yeah.
And so then during that time when you,
when you were still had like stitches,
but,
and I know we talked
about this a little bit,
but you had like the triangle thing
hanging above you or you start doing pull
ups and you start trying to do some
kind of upper body workout at that time.
Yeah, I mean, once I got to Walter Reed,
I met my physical therapist that day and
we set up the time I was going to come
in,
uh,
seven o'clock frosh occupational therapy
at eight o'clock for physical there.
And we'd be just doing stuff on the mat
tables so you don't have to be boring
legs and you can be
working on other stuff.
While you're waiting for that stuff to
heal. So yeah, I'd be doing kind of dips.
I've raised my,
the arms and my wheelchair up really
high and I do dips and you know,
they had stuff you could do, like a trunk
strengthening exercises. You know, I,
I wasn't the first double above knee
amputee to come through Walter Reed.
We've been at war for nine years,
so they had this,
all of these exercises already set
up. So I'd come in, I do my exercises,
lay a legless for the day and this work
on what I could while we waited for that
stuff to while we waited for my skin and
we're just waiting on my skin basically
to heal. How did you feel, like,
how did you feel regaining your strength
and your upper body were, were you, like,
were you like back on the gains path? You
know what I mean? Were you like, okay,
I just did,
you know,
yesterday I did eight pull ups and today
I'm going to do 10 and the next day I'm,
did you get, did you get yourself right
back in like the old school workout mode?
Uh, just back on the path
when I was still in the,
when I was still in the
hospital at Bethesda, uh,
I would go into physical therapy,
but he,
you guys got to pull up bar or anything
like that and then yeah, we have one,
they had one in like a closet and
I was, and I saw, I was like, Hey,
I want to do some pull ups.
And so I set the pullup record for
people that had come through and it got
broken by a seal later. But uh, so yeah,
I set that pull up. It was like,
let me see. I never lost the,
the desire to see what I could
do. You know, I was like, yeah,
I'm going to do a max set of pull ups
and see how many I could do still.
But yeah, it was definitely
frustrating cause I, I was,
I lost a lot of muscle mass, but you know,
once you started doing those exercises,
like every time I came in I wanted to go
at one more or two more or a little bit
longer. And I had that same attitude
when I started walking. You know,
the first day I started walking,
I'd maybe stood in my legs for two minutes
and the next day I was like, you know,
I'm going to try three minutes today or
last yesterday I walked one time around
the little track, I'm going
to go twice, you know,
just slowly building up and you know,
same. So what's that process like getting,
getting standing up for the first time?
What does that feel like?
It's wild. I mean, the first
thing you gotta do is you've
got to get cast it. It's,
they have to make the sockets
that go onto your, uh, stumps.
And they do it,
they make they a wrap this
plaster around your stump and they
mold it so that it's putting pressure on
the right spots. And they take that off,
they fill it up with some
other kind of plaster material.
Uh,
they take the,
the cast they made off and then
they pour plastic around that.
And so then you have,
you're basically a mold of your
leg and the first time you,
the first time you step up in it is not
comfortable at all or it hurts a lot
because you're putting pressure on points
that you didn't before and they kind
of have to see you stand
up and you're like, okay,
well there's a spot right
back there that hurts a lot.
So they take it off and they use this
hairdryer and make it hot and they kind of
mold that. They push it out against
so it's not against that spot anymore.
And then you put it back on,
okay, that's comfortable.
And then you do it for the other one.
And for me, yeah. I mean I could,
you could,
you can't,
I couldn't just walk from the first try.
I had to have my arms on the,
on the uh, the parallel bars
and like it was, you know,
that slow thing that you see kind of in,
in movies where I took them maybe
10 steps and that was it for me.
First Time
I've walked five balance or is
it a little bit musculature?
Like is it you're using different muscles?
Yeah.
So you definitely,
you're walking in a different
way then your body's designed to,
so when you walk you just go,
you know,
kind of forward and back
here with your legs.
You're Ben Bend at the knee to get it
past the ground so it doesn't skip on the
ground. Whereas when you're
double above knee amputee, uh,
you have to swing your legs out to the
side at first cause you don't have that
knee joint.
You can't just bring them forward.
So you kind of have to learn that
and it's a lot of the balance your,
your musculature has to kind of get used
to what muscles you're using to keep
your balance now.
Uh,
so that has to be figured out by
your brain and your spinal cord.
And then on top of that,
just developing the resistance to the,
the discomfort does,
it's really not comfortable.
And that's kind of probably
what I didn't get tired.
Like I could have stood for longer,
but it's just my legs were hurting so bad.
Yeah. Like you could run a mile or
you could run a marathon or whatever,
but if you're, if you're, if you have
a blister on your tail, you know,
then that's going to stop you.
It seems like the balance thing,
like sometimes I've heard my like
let's say hurt my ankle or hurt my,
even something as stupid as hurt,
like had a big cut on my,
on the bottom of my foot.
Yeah.
And so you can't use your foot the way
you normally do and it totally throws off
your balance.
And I can't even imagine you're,
you're now trying to balance through the,
through the perception of your
nerves in your, in your stumps and,
and how that feels and how you
got to kind of adjust for that.
That's gotta be like learning
how to ski or something,
learning how to do a balanced type
sport, surf, something like that. I can,
I can only imagine that that's gotta
be what it's like to get your brain and
like you said,
your brain and your spinal cord to
be able to adapt to what's happening
underneath you when you have a totally
new set of sensors down there now.
Yeah.
And you'd have to also keep,
have to keep it for a double above knee
amputee and all this stuff I'm saying is
this double above knee amputees.
But uh,
you're also losing two joints
that help with balance.
So enabled body person, they have, if
they want to make a small adjustment,
they use their ankle and then they can
use the knee and then they can use the
hip. But you know, double above
knee, we, all we have is the hip.
So it's an extra challenge learning how
to make these adjustments with just,
just your hips. But you know,
it's kind of, it's a lot like a,
a dog that has a missing leg.
You know,
the first time he goes to walk he kinda
just figures it out and he is learns
that new method and it's kind of, it's
pretty much a similar thing. You know,
you adapt to it and you just,
you figure it out
ain't on the first
prosthetics that you get.
Are they articulated or they just like
straight cause I know what you've got
now. It was pretty, they look
pretty damn advanced to me.
I mean you can get you looking like a
freaking term terminator robot over there.
Are you getting that first?
Cause it's an articulating because,
oh um,
so yeah,
it's in the balance in that realm.
They keep you really short while you're
relearning that balance because just in
case you fall. So while you're relearning
that balance and keep you really short.
So basically I could,
if I was going to fall,
I just put my hand out pretty much
and catch myself on the ground.
And so while you'll read
learning this balance,
they keep you nice and short
because your center of gravity,
it's going to be lower.
So it's a lot easier.
And then also you kind
of learn that hip motion,
so they keep you nice and short
just to make it a lot easier.
And then as you get better,
as you get stronger and a
little bit better moving around,
they make you a little bit taller. But
there's no knee joint. It's just a,
you go from your socket and there's a
Bates straight cylindrical pylon made out
of metal and that goes to the prosthetic
foot and you probably have a shoe on
the foot and then that's it. So
you, you stay really short, uh,
for three,
four months.
And at this time are you already thinking
about like what kind of crazy stuff
you're going to do once
you figure this shit out?
I, once I had found out
about the Paralympics, uh,
that was probably my first week when
I was at Bethesda in the hospital bed,
just researching.
I wanted to get back in the gym
and I didn't know what I could,
what I'd still be able to do in the gym.
So I was maybe looking for,
I forget what I searched,
but like disabled sports or disabled
working out or something like that.
And I found the pair Olympics and at
the time I wasn't saying to myself,
I'm definitely going to commit to going
because they didn't know much about it
and I still had this big, I
still had to take, you know,
a year and a half to relearn how to
walking. And that was numero uno, uh,
to learn how to do. But yeah, it
was kind of in the back of my head,
I had found about it and
I was thinking about it.
That's kind of how things work for me.
I can,
the idea is impregnated
initially and like I, okay,
that's an interesting idea. You know,
Paralympics. Okay, that's interesting.
I go ride my bike, cross
country. Okay, interesting.
And then I think about it a little
bit more and time goes on. I think.
Yeah, I could probably do that, you know?
And then eventually I'll get to
a point where like, all right,
I'm going to do it and then I commit
to it. And so at this point, you know,
I hadn't committed to it,
but I was researching and you know,
contemplating and figuring
out the feasibility and you
know how I would go about
it if I wanted to try
and make the attempt.
That seems like that would have a
massive positive impact on your mindset.
So something that I talk about and I
talked about with Jordan Peterson and he
agreed with me on this idea of finding
a new mission and having a new mission.
So a lot of times,
I'm sure you've seen this too,
I've definitely seen it when guys get
out of the military for whatever reason,
when they get out,
the guys that do well are the guys that
have a new mission to go on and on,
whether it's a new job or whether they're
going to be a super dad or whether
they're going to go to school and
get good grades. Those guys do good.
And in their new mission,
the guys that have the most trouble from
what I've seen most of the time is the
guys that don't have a, a new mission
there. They get out and they say, well,
you know, I might do this, I might
do that, I might do something else.
But what they're really doing is nothing.
They don't have any real direction.
And they end up, you know, what's
the mission? The mission becomes,
have another drink, you know,
uh, do something unproductive,
do what feels good immediately.
And it's becomes problematic.
But it seems like the fact that
you found something immediately,
you realize that there was a
goal that you could go after,
even if it was only a little idea at
first. That idea can carry you a long way.
Yeah. And you know, also, luckily
for me it wasn't like, it was,
it's not like I was in Afghanistan one
day and then separated the next day.
I kind of had a mission that was,
you know,
it came about, uh, about by its own
because, you know, I just lost my legs.
My first mission was learn how to walk.
So I had that right away. But you know,
while I was taking that time to do
that, I was thinking about, you know,
what I'm going to do after?
I get out and you know every,
every guy that gets out of the military,
you know most of the time you know when
your contract's going to end so you can
start thinking about it earlier. But
it's definitely no, I agree with you.
Having having something to work
towards is a hugely important,
I'll, I'll tell you that
even what you just said.
So there's people that they
get out and you're saying,
hey, I had this new mission cause I had
to at least learn how to walk. There's,
there's people that they get out and
they don't have a new mission and they
don't figure one out and that becomes
problematic. And I, and you know what,
let's not just apply it to the military.
I'll apply this to every human being
happy kids get out of college happens when
kids get out of high school happens
when you go through, you know,
you've got something that you're looking
at or something that you're focused on
and boom, it goes away. Well
now what are you going to do?
And if you don't line something
up and don't focus on something,
you don't take aim at something,
well then you're not going anywhere.
Oh yeah. It's like when
you're, you know how you shoot,
do you guys call it table to when you're
kind of working on a shooting like
targets that are right in front of you.
We don't call it terrible too.
We call it table two is table one is
kind of the long distance drive range.
But it's almost kind of like when you're,
when you're doing that and you,
they say, okay shoot this
guy twice and that guy twice.
So you do that and then at the end you
scan and make sure there's nobody else
around. So it's kind of like doing that.
Your mission is to shoot the thing,
but you also have to be looking
out for other stuff. Yeah,
yeah. No, absolutely. You know it's,
it's funny too cause I think about like
when you think about kids that you grew
up with and like high school,
they get done with high school and
there's some kids that, Oh God,
I'm going to go into college. I'm
going to go to military. Yeah.
There's some kids that don't know what
they're going to do after high school and
what happens to him. You know, what
happens to them? They, they, they,
they flounder around. They get a little
job here that they don't really like,
they do something else.
They don't really like,
you just have to be careful of that.
You have to be careful.
And I'd say as a parent, that's something
to look out for it too. You know,
you gotta look out for your kids and make
sure your kids have something to focus
on.
Have something that they're striving for.
Because if you don't have
anything to strive for,
if you're not trying to go anywhere,
if you're not on some kind of mission,
that that's problematic.
Yeah. And you know, so since I had that,
everything I did during the day,
it mattered to me because I had something
that was vastly important to me that I
was trying to achieve.
So if I didn't care about
whether or not I walked again,
then I could just roll
around in my wheelchair.
And it wouldn't matter if I worked
out that day. But since I really,
I learned how to walk again and be
totally independent and get rid of my
wheelchair and all that stuff to be able
to run and do everything I was able to
do before that was, you know,
the most important thing.
And so I fed off that when,
you know,
I didn't feel like going into therapy
because I was my back hurt or whatever.
And the, you know, whether
or not I do that third,
fourth set of balanced drills or you know,
a strengthening exercises, you
know, that had an effect on,
on that goal. And, and so, and the same
thing with going to the Paralympics.
You know, I wanted to be
able to, to explore that.
And so the stuff I was doing
in the hospital, it mattered.
So this is interesting because,
uh,
we were actually talking about this
the other day. So you end up with,
and I guess again, I'm just
trying to break down. Obviously
you're a person that,
that can push through pain and
suffering and push through short term,
uh, challenges in order to
achieve a longterm goal.
And I think that the way you
break it down is you're looking,
even when you're, you're suffering from
a challenge right now, you're, you're,
you know,
I don't feel like doing another balance
to drill because my back is sore or
whatever. Yeah. Well people hit that,
those kinds of obstacles every single day,
you know, they don't want to get up in
the morning, they don't want to work out,
they don't want to do the last set, et
Cetera, et Cetera, et cetera. But you had,
you tie those small term,
short term things,
the short term pain because you have a
longterm goal that you really care about.
Yeah, exactly. I mean it's, it's all a
matter of what matters to you most, uh,
you know, is what's more important
to you learning for or for me,
learning how to walk again
or staying in bed today.
You know, staying in bed would be nice.
It would feel good. I'd be able to watch.
I think what I was watching on Netflix,
I was watching 24 of
the series on Netflix.
I can watch an entire series of 24 today
or something and I could do that and
that would be fun. But
at the end of the day,
I'm still not gonna be any closer
to being able to walk again.
And I would much rather be
able to walk everywhere.
I went totally independently then
find out what happens to Jack Bauer,
you know, so, and then, you know,
at the same time, you know, if,
if you're working on,
you know what people like to leave it.
If you want to lose weight and you know,
do you,
would you rather have a milkshake mint
chocolate chip milkshake or would you
rather it cook cookie dough milkshake?
Would you rather have that milkshake
or would you rather, you know,
be able to run 10 miles or not get winded
when you're walking with your kids or
in a playing with your kids. It's like
what, which one matters to you more?
And I always pick that bigger
one because I mean it's,
it's pretty straightforward for me.
The delayed gratification is the
delayed gratification versus the instant
gratification delayed but much more
enjoyable. Yeah, much more durable.
Definitely better and
better for your whole life.
Last longer too by the way. Yeah.
Yup. And enduring. It's an enduring,
lasting, longer lasting, enduring
thing that you end up with.
[inaudible] that's what people
need to tap into. That right there.
That's good. How you have a
like a way, like almost like a,
I don't want to say scaffolding, but
like a way to look at it. Like how you,
when you're presented with like an option,
you're, hey, you're conscious of it. B,
you have a way to look at
it where you're like, okay,
which one is important to
me? Which one, you know,
is Jack Bauer in 24 important to me?
Whereas walking important to me, you know,
so most people,
they just on how they feel,
you know,
I really don't feel like doing this so
I'll do this or I really am in the mood
for this, so I'll do it kind of thing.
They don't like kind of in a way,
break it down like how you do just,
yeah,
just from moment to moment
where you'll be like, okay,
I have this way to look at it and I'm
gonna look at it this way and then I can
re or, or behave, you
know that it actually is,
that's pretty a good way of looking at it.
You put it into a binary calculation,
right?
There's two options. Don't go like, am I
going to do the thing that's gonna make,
make me better in the long run or the
thing that's gonna make me worse in the
long run and feels good right now.
Which one are you going to do this?
You just make that into a binary
decision. Yeah, but he didn't his release.
So simple.
Which one's important to me and it's,
it's almost like a black or white.
No. Which ones? What's
driving your behavior?
And then you can even take
it another step. Like, again,
like the losing the weight example,
you,
you will either want to have the milkshake
or you want to be able to, you know,
walk around with the guys. Even
if you don't care about, you know,
being overweight or you're not
being able to move your body around,
you know, you can still lose
the weight by figuring out what,
even if you don't feel
like going on a diet,
like what is it that necessitates
you to go on the Diet. And for me,
so I didn't want necessarily to
train every day for the Paralympics.
I didn't necessarily want to ride my bike
every day on my bike ride or run them.
I didn't necessarily enjoy doing that.
I didn't feel like doing it,
but I had to do that because my
goal necessitated me to do that.
So if you're struggling to
get motivated to lose weight,
just for the sake of losing weight,
find something that necessitates you to
lose weight, that really matters to you.
Like, you know, not dying when
you're 55 of a heart attack,
that'll do it. Um, there's,
there's three things that you
talked about on the law. Well,
we talked about it on the last podcast,
but I kind of breathed it,
breezed over them. And I, and I
realized when I listened to it again,
I should've talked to you a little
bit more in depth because I think it's
helpful for people to hear again to
hear from you who's overcome incredible
challenges. There's three things
that you talked about. Um,
and it's actually in the journal, which
you, which you have a journal Online, um,
on, on Rob Jones, journey.com. But, and
this is there as well, but number one,
number one is writing down goals.
Number two is celebrating milestones
and number three is overcoming
rationalization. So let's just
break those down a little bit.
How strict were you with
writing down your goals?
And do you still do that?
Um, I don't, I guess I don't physically,
you'll have a pen and
paper and write it down.
I think what I do now is I'll announce
it or something like that, or I'll,
I'll make it known that that's
what I'm planning on doing check.
So when I decided to do
my marathon challenge,
I did it on Facebook or something,
or I'd put it on all my social media
platforms and then it's out there now.
Okay, now I'm responsible. This
is beyond writing it down. Yeah.
This is like writing it down or selling
it to the world or telling people that
you want to have the respect
of like if I told my wife Pam,
like I, I'm going to do this. And she,
okay,
she knows I'm a person that she respects
me for living up to what I say I'm
going to do. I don't want to lose
her respect. So now, um, even,
even though I would
have done it regardless,
I'm not saying I would've
said I wouldn't do it.
And then that fallout or
back out I another mission,
even if the mission became not
important to me, there was another,
another aspect of that. And you know,
you, you've committed to it at that.
So that's another aspect of my personality
where not only do I want to help
veterans, but now I've committed
to some, I said I'm going to do,
and I've given my word and now there's
people that are kind of relying on me to,
to do that. And if I, if I say I'm
going to do it, then I say, oh,
we could never mind.
I actually,
I'm not going to do it then they're
actually losing a little bit of hope.
Maybe. Cause they were, they were
hoping I was going to do it and they,
we're going to get something out of
it now, now that I'm not doing it.
So they're kind of losing
that, that benefit. Yeah.
Makes Sense. Yeah. So it's
beyond writing it down.
It's writing it down or announcing,
announcing it. Celebrating milestones.
Yeah.
So it's really hard to stay motivated
when there's this obscure goal that is two
years away or a year and a half
away and you're not really seeing
huge progress towards everybody. You
getting like a millimeter every day. Um,
it gets old, you know, you feel really
motivated in the beginning, right.
Cause you're pumped up and you have
tons of energy and then when you,
and at the end you can see it,
you can smell the barn and you can see it.
So you find the extra energy in
your, in yourself. But in that,
that middle part where you're not,
you're not even sure that you're going
to be able to do it and it's so far away
and you're like, man, I'm, I'm
only like halfway and I still have,
I've done all this stuff and now I
still have to do all that again. Um,
it helps too.
Okay.
Pick stuff along the way that,
you know, is going to, uh,
to be there. That kind of,
you know, all right. I'm not, I'm
going for that far away thing,
but right now I'm going to that.
And that's what excites me.
So when I was in the hospital,
getting in the wheelchair was
my first little milestone, the,
I had a year and I didn't even know how
long it was going to take me to learn
how to walk again. Right. At least I
was thinking like a year and a half,
two years. Yeah, that's a long time
and with a lot of work in between.
So all right,
right now does get into the
wheelchair and then all right,
well learn how to do it on your own and
then after that get your legs and then
figure out how to walk with only one
cane instead of two canes keeping you up
and then drop the other cane
and that's another milestone.
And then you get your bionic knees and
so you probably go back to the canes for
Awhile and then when you have those you
take away that cane and then take away
the other one.
And then you learn how to run and then
you learn how to do ride the bike or
whatever. So you just keep finding
little things along the way.
And you know when I was doing,
when I was training for triathlons,
I do this on a small scale.
I would have ate two minute
all out sprints on my bike
to do and I'd be sitting
there on the first one and I'm like,
oh my God, I have eight of these to do.
The first one would just blow me up.
I'm like, Oh my God, I have seven more.
And I would just be like, you know
what, just focus on this next one.
Just do this one and then we'll focus
on the next one after that. And then,
so just, I would even trick myself
sometimes I'd be like, all right,
I'd be at my sixth one, I'd
be so tired. And the arc,
you know what if I can maintain this speed
or if I can make my power maintain my
power output for this entire seventh one,
I'll skip the eighth one is I'll treat
myself, I'll skip the eighth one.
I do the seventh one,
I'd be like, all right,
I'll just do the eighth
one cause you know, I,
I do that something to treat
myself, you know? So, yeah.
So it's interesting. So what, you've
talked with his back on me in these,
in this thing, and I've talked about
this before. I've talked about before,
multiple times. Uh, I don't even
know if I've talked to from the Pie,
I must have talked about in the podcast,
but I've taught,
I talk about it with people,
which is you have long range stuff and
you have short range stuff and what you
have to do is you have to put the both
pose in your mind and you have to shift
the focus back on forth,
back and forth between the two to
whichever one is going to get you moving.
Because when the goal is too
far away, you're like, ah,
you know what is not going to really
make a difference if I skip this thing
today, it's not that big of a deal. The
goal is too far away. It gets blurry and,
and so what you need is you need to put,
okay, just the obs do the short call.
Well, after the daily grind
beats you down on the short goal,
you start to forget what the longterm goal
is and you guy, you know what? I don't,
I don't really need to do this
workout today or I don't need to do,
I can eat this food or I can do whatever
because it's not going to make a big
impact on the long thing. You
know, w what am I doing anyways?
Then you've got to look back at the
long goal and that's right. I have this,
this thing that I'm trying to make happen
and it's these small goals that are
going to get me there.
So you got to shift.
You got to have both the longterm goal
that's gotta be something that you really
want to achieve. You've got to
understand why, you know, like you said,
you got to understand why it
is you want to achieve it.
You can't just be something that you
don't care about and then you got to have
that as your primary driving force.
But your secondary driving force,
which is equally important, is these
short term things that you can get to,
that are there, that are close, that are
you can achieve even if it's two minutes.
Even if it's, I did Tabata a Tabata
on the air bike the other day,
bro. Yeah, I was there.
I was like, you know,
and my daughter was there.
My wrestled,
my daughter that Russell's,
she was there and so she's kind
of like calling me out but,
but in a positive way. She's
like a positive person. Yeah.
She was hyping me and I put out hard
cause she was there going, come on.
You know what it's like when your,
your daughter's going to come on,
dad pushed harder. You're like, oh
awesome. Yeah I'm going to get some,
I want him to die. You know, you know
the blood tastes in your mouth, you know?
Yeah. Whatever that thing is. So I had
some of that going on but, but yeah,
you have the short term and
you have a longterm goals.
You got to have them both and you gotta
they've gotta be attached somehow.
But you've got to lean on which one is
going to get you to do what you know
you're supposed to do.
You know you're supposed to do,
that's a little psychology behind
just getting after it. Right.
This is a little psychology behind just
getting after it. A little head games.
You Echo and I were talking
the other day and he was all,
he was kind of surprised because I was
talking about there's a one workout that
I do, which is PR. It's I,
it's my hardest and most
brutal workout and it's in,
it's in the field manual,
but it's a 20 rep squat.
You Do,
you do,
you take a weight that you can squat
10 times and you do it 20 times.
And like after rep 12
every single rep is just,
it just, it's, it's pain.
And then you do that and then you lay
on the floor for 20 minutes and then you
get up and you do it again and you lay
on the floor for 20 minutes and you'd get
up and do it again. So it's three
sets in one hour to one hour workout.
But I was telling an
echo, I was like, yeah,
there's times where I'm in the middle of
like set two and I'm on rep 14 and I'm
like, I don't even, I don't
even think I want to be strong.
I don't want to be strong.
I don't, I don't even care
from healthy. I just want to,
I just want to just this,
this, this is horrible.
Why would I be doing this right
now? This is stupid. Yeah. Relief.
Any kind of weave.
But,
but actually what gets me to push
through those is I think to myself,
Oh, you hear that? That's actual
weakness in your mind right now.
Actual living weakness gets a
voice in your mind right now.
Are you going to listen to it?
Are you gonna listen to it? No.
You're not going to listen to it. Are
you doing, I'm a straight through or you,
yes,
that's it's,
it's an old school workout that
I originally got from, well,
there's a book called super squats.
There's a book called super squats if,
and that book has this workup,
but the, actually that book
only has you do one set.
You do one set. I was the idiot
that sought to myself. Well,
if one set is good, how about I do
three sets of that and it's brutal.
It's brutal. Yeah. It's like, well,
I have to do it now. Yeah, no,
that's another thing. That's
another thing I say is, is you know,
if you don't really feel like
working out, okay, that's fine.
Write down what you're going
to do and then just do it.
Just turn off your brain and just
do what you're supposed to do.
Just put the numbers down
and do what you're supposed to do.
You're not, every day is all happy,
you know? This is great. I'm
feeling myself getting stronger. No,
I feel like I'm gonna Puke. That's not
cool, but that's good. That's like,
like kind of like you're talking about
how if you go by how you feel every day.
Like I feel like doing this
or I'm feeling motivated,
feeling where it's just like
you're saying rob, where are you?
You are in the habit of
looking at it a certain way.
Like what's important to me, how you
feel. It's kind of shuffled to the side.
It's like what's important. Okay,
now I'm going to get moving. Yeah.
Feelings are not,
not generally not a good thing to rely
on to make things generally not a good,
they can trick you though.
You know how like, just like,
how are you saying in the beginning,
you know when you first decided to do
something you don't like New Year's
resolution? What are, you know,
like it's real common thing
where at the BNA exciting,
let's start this new thing
and then at the end it can be,
because you see the goal right there,
we're about to do it, you know,
kind of thing. But in the middle
it's like, yeah, so feeling can,
I don't want to say, yeah, you're,
you're right. Don't rely on it,
but it can trick you because in the
beginning when you have that feeling like
you want to,
it's like,
it's almost like you think it's
going to be there the whole time.
That's a new thing. This is
the new thing from me. I'm,
I've never felt like this
about anything I've ever done.
I'm excited about this one. Then it
goes away and then you're like, oh,
we're not doing that.
Always had that energy at the
end, like of a, I bet like the,
the last one of that to
Bata that you did was like,
well where was all that energy?
Have you guys ever heard of the central
governor theory of fatigue? Well,
it's basically about two different,
so see if I can do this without making
it super long. There's two different,
we got eight hours of recording time.
There's two different 18
theories on how your body,
I guess processes fatigue or what it
exactly it is. And so there's the,
I think it's called the catastrophic
theory where basically your journey,
you tabatas and something
breaks down and then like, uh,
you run out of energy totally deplete
yourself of glycogen or whatever.
And then you, you can't because
you don't have any more glycogen,
so you muscles just don't work.
And then there's this other theory,
which is kind of the accepted theory
now that your brain has a governor in it
and it's,
it's getting all this information
from your muscles and your senses.
It's getting all this information.
It's calculating how much
energy it meters out.
And so when you're doing your Tabatas,
the first one,
you have all sorts of energy.
So your brain is like go and it's
connected to your subconscious and your
constant kind of connect because you kind
of know how many sets you do and your
brain actually calculate that.
Calculate to that end too.
It's how it decides to do this.
So that first one you're like, oh,
if tons of glycogen available me so I
can just blow through this first one.
And then as you go, uh, your,
your, your brain's getting the
signals that you're running,
you run out of glycogen,
maybe the calcium to contract the
muscles is kind of getting low.
And so it kind of dials you back,
uh,
automatically by contracting less
muscle fibers. And so you kind of get,
and it makes you feel fatigued.
So they say that fatigue is actually a
fatigue and pain are actually emotion.
So it makes you feel these emotions,
fatigue,
fatigue.
So it makes you feel this and
it kind of dials you back.
And then on that last one, you know that
this is your last one. So it's like,
all right, well we're done after this,
so I'm going to let it go. And then
is the theory,
so it's kind of that kind of book.
So there is this thing called the gold.
I think I told you this,
a Gold Ji 10 I think I'm pronouncing
it correctly. Golgi tendon organs,
a little regulator, and
they're essentially like
clusters of nerves that going.
And so this is more like high intensity.
Like I'm gonna do a two rep,
one rep to rep through your rep,
whatever Max.
So that's regulated by your brain.
So when you get too much stress on
your muscle, your brain says, hey,
that's too much stress. You're going to
stop the muscle contraction or let off.
Usually it stops it. That's why if
you go for a two rep Max, one rep Max,
you can get it here and then you
just poop and it fails. You fail.
But if you can get, if the, if it
doesn't fire, you'll go and you'll push,
you'll push. Sometimes you'll
pause and you can still put like,
why did you just fail the other time? You
know what I mean? Yeah, it's that. So,
um, and then if you go
to lower intensity stuff,
then it goes more into the glyco like
you ever seen like a marathon runner or
you know,
some real long like I don't know,
an obstacle courses where the guy's
like mentally you can tell he's,
he's not going to quit but his legs
are like shivering and shaking and he,
it's like he's almost like he's going
to pass out or something like that. It,
so that's more of that. That's like
your physical capability, the energy,
the physical energy system
is failing. That's, you know,
so that's a different thing.
So it's funny that would be bound,
I'm sure when you were in boot
camp or going through buds,
like how many pushups are you going to do?
You're just going to keep doing pushups.
Yeah.
You literally just keep doing push ups
and push ups and push ups and pushups and
personable.
Some push ups and push ups and pushups
and sometimes you lay there for on flat
on your face for like 20 seconds.
But then they say keep going.
And so you just keep going and then you
keep going for a little while and then
you lay on your face for a little while
and then you keep going like you can
just keep going for,
yeah.
Unless you get to that now sometimes on
like a run someone would pass out and
like that would be that.
Yeah. What's that? Yeah.
According to this there would be your,
your brain basically shut you to saw you
and you see somebody running at the end
of a marathon and they're like the,
their legs aren't working.
That's kind of their body.
They've been able to somehow through
all the pain and all that stuff,
they've been able to put,
they'd been motivated to push through and
then finally your body gets to a point
that if we keep going,
we are going to die,
so I'm shutting you down and it just hits
the hits the shutdown button and then
your legs a stop where I just,
it will just stop contracting your
muscles or I don't remember how we got on
this subject.
Yeah. Pushing through.
The engine is still going,
but the fuel doesn't get to the engine.
So the engine starts,
you know that there's a
little math on situation,
but in like a higher intensity stuff,
it's, it seems like, you know, he'd,
given what I, what I know about
the Golgi tendon organ situation,
it seems like you're a Golgi tendon
expert. Yes. But we'll hear, this is,
this is when I really, I learned about
it in college, but when I tore my bicep,
you know,
guys will lift real hard and just tear
their muscle off the bone because when
you train heavy, you're
training to, to, um,
to what he's done to mitigate the
effects of the Golgi tendon or that's,
or like huge rushes of adrenaline.
And we'll do it too. You know,
you hear the story about them,
the lady, she saw the car,
left the car off the kid off the kid.
Yeah.
So basically you're just
bypassing the Golgi tendon,
Oregon because of these
extreme situations. But by
nature, try lift up a car,
you kind of can't. And the same, I mean
the, you know the, well most of us can,
but when you do like a
one rep Max like Uber,
when you test for that and you see it
all the time where you know the guy,
let's say, I don't know, he does
three 55 right? Like he even,
there's like a pause because he's pushing
so hard and he's barely any Guinea
gets it put on three 65 pounds more.
He gets it like a quarter of the way up
and it just falls on his chest, you know,
because it fires and boom muscle shutdown.
That's what that is.
Yeah.
And when you're doing the heavy,
you're also teaching your kind of
teaching your body to most people can only
contract 30% of their muscles at one time
because their brain doesn't let them,
cause if they attracted all of your
muscle fibers at the same time,
it could produce an injury.
So when you lift heavy,
your brain has kind of
learning, all right, I can,
I can can drag this many. Oh,
okay, now I can contract this many.
And like the best people still can.
Only contract like 50% of their, their
muscle five Olympic lifters. Yeah.
That's like, cause they're
just, yeah, exactly. Or like
really heavy power lifters.
Mm. So now on the,
on the last podcast we talked
about the Paralympic growing. So,
and we talked about you biking
across across the country again,
which is from Maine to San Diego.
And we,
and again if you want to get people
should go listen to those on,
on podcasts 92 and, but, but
when you were on last time,
you were talking about
your latest announcement,
your latest goal that you had written
down in and announced to everybody,
which was that you were going
to run 31 marathons in 31 days,
which is just kind of um,
a little bit psycho.
And actually you wrote down,
I'm going to read this excerpt from your,
from your online journal.
Okay.
Here we go. Back to the journal. I can't,
this is an expression that is vilified
in our minds beginning at a young age.
Every time a young child announces
this decision, they are corrected.
The first adult that hears it, ask them
whether or not they have even tried.
Generally, this confrontation will
result in the child giving their task.
Another attempts until their attention
span moves on to something else.
The adult will see this and chuckle to
themselves with knowledge that this is
just a child who has yet to learn the
art of art and virtue of perseverance.
By the time this child comes of age,
however,
they will have been told by adults more
times than they could count that there
is no such thing as can't.
It is interesting then to think about
how many adults seem to proclaim this
expression in their lives.
It is because,
is it because like many things
that adults tell children,
they are simply telling the
child a general rule that
the child must follow but
can be broken once one has grown or
is it because these adults are simply
repeating what they were told as children
without thoroughly examining what the
phrase I can't truly suggests.
If you confronted an adult that claims
they can't do something with the same
question about whether
or not they have tried,
the answer will almost always be yes.
Adults have learned enough to know that
it is unreasonable to say they can't
until they have at least tried once.
Therefore,
the real question that we
should be asking in responses,
have you tried everything?
Have you exhausted every possible
option, scenario, combination,
tool and approach?
I do not simply refer to the ones that
you knew of at the time you decided to
undertake your task.
I mean have you re also researched
possibilities that you had known about?
Have you determined whether or not there
is another person out there that has
performed the exact same task you are
attempting or at least something similar?
Have you exhausted this research? Have
you read every book, blog, Journal,
magazine,
bathroom stall and website?
If the answer to any of these questions
is no, then go back and try again.
Because if you don't because you don't
truly know if you can do something until
you've tried absolutely everything.
The fact of the matter
is that rarely if ever,
is the answer to all of these questions.
Yes.
Therefore, what is it that people
actually mean when they say,
I can't a more accurate but more
verbose way of saying it would be,
I don't care about or want enough this
task or the results and benefits of it in
order to do all that is
necessary to achieve it.
I was told countless numbers of times
by people during my month of marathons
that they couldn't run one marathon,
let alone 31 straight.
Every now and then when I had time,
I would discuss what they'd said.
We would jointly conclude that if
something they cared about and depended on
them doing so,
it would be possible.
The most common example I used was if
someone had a gun to your child's head,
do you think you could
do it? Then therefore,
the phrase,
I can't denotes a lack of investment
as opposed to a lack of potential or
ability.
I do not mean to say that every person
I had this conversation with should have
had the motivation to run marathons.
It was something that I decided to do,
not them. I merely wanted to express
to them what I am expressing here.
Given the right purpose and enough time,
you can,
okay,
what happens if someone
has said they can't?
We have asked them if they've
done everything and the
rare cases happen and they
honestly say yes. Do we concede
that then they can't? Nope.
If everything in existence
has been attempted enough
to determine that it won't
work,
then congratulations.
You've been awarded the honor of being
the person who must invent the method or
the tool or determine the right
combination, whether or not you will.
Once again boils down to
how much you care and time.
It may end up being that a person
ends up trying for their entire life.
But I suggest removing the phrase I
can't from your lexicon and replacing it
with,
I can't yet.
Okay.
Do this so that you don't risk being
on your death bed saying I didn't.
Okay.
So, yeah, and I don't mean to like
if somebody comes up and says,
I can't do something, I'm not going
to say, I'm not going to, you know,
and I know what they're really
saying. Um, and I don't,
I'm not going to judge them
and I don't care if you,
if you don't care about this thing
and it doesn't matter to me, but, uh,
you should just be a little bit
more accurate in what you're saying.
You know, I'm not, like if you, if you
say I can't run a marathon, that's fine.
That's fine. You don't, you
don't want to run a marathon.
You don't care about running.
It doesn't matter to you.
And that's your personal choice, you know?
But, uh, to say that you can't do it,
having never even attempted it, uh,
is just not an accurate statement.
So where'd you get the idea to
attempt 31 marathons in 31 days?
So, uh, after my bike ride,
I tried to make the Paralympics for
triathlon and I did not succeed.
I failed and that attempt,
but with every failure,
there is a lesson learned.
And I learned when I was training for
a triathlon that I was pretty good at
running.
I was able to run the five k triathlon,
a five k distance at the end of
the triathlon at 18 minutes flat,
which is pretty fast. That's, that's
maxing out the Marine Corps. Pft.
You can't get any faster than that.
And so it's pretty fast. So I, and I,
I realized, you know, I, I've,
I've decent a decent talent for running
and I'd run the Marine Corps marathon
the year before and I,
so I knew that I could run a marathon
and I was just kind of,
you know,
after this failed attempt
to make the Paralympics,
cause it's kind of thinking about
what my next mission could be.
And I wanted to do another
thing like my bike ride.
And I had heard about other people
doing this kind of thing where they do,
you know, 50 marathons in 50 days
in 50 states or 50 iron mans,
50 days in 50 states. So, you know,
I decided I wanted to do marathons,
um,
and I kind of put my own little spin
on it and I said, well, you know what,
I want to get this story and in
front of as many eyeballs as I can.
So to do 50 minute earth to do 31 marathon
straight in my backyard isn't really
going to do that.
So I need to do,
I could go down to the trail everyday for
31 straight and do it and nobody would
ever care and nobody would
ever find out about it.
And it'd be the same amount of, it'd
be just as impressive to do. Um,
and so all right, I want to get this in
front of as many eyeballs as possible.
So I need to do it in major cities where
there's a lot of people that can find
out about it and spread it that
way. And so I figured, all right,
I'll take that same formula and do 31
marathons and all in different cities.
And I picked 31 because I was trying
to figure if a good number. So I,
I started with the 20 number,
which is the number associated with
number of veterans suicides every day.
I figured that'd be a pretty powerful
number. But after thinking about that,
I kind of figured it wasn't enough.
It wasn't enough marathons in a row.
And I figured by the time,
more marathons,
by the time I got
started with that I'd be,
and by the time I got kind of some
momentum going and pretty much be over,
and so I didn't figure to have it as
big an impact. So I wanted to do more.
So I was like, well what about
50 and so I was like, well, okay,
50 I could probably do it
if I train enough for it,
but 50 might be too many,
it might be too long.
So by the time I started getting
going and then I, you know,
I'm at 40 I still have 10 more people
are going to kind of maybe lose interest
and be like, oh, is that
guy still doing that?
Because I found out about the iron
cowboy doing his 50 iron mans in 50 days.
And I kind of had that same
thing where I was like, Oh hey,
this is gonna be awesome.
I was following him for the first couple
of weeks and then eventually I'm like,
oh, does he still is either finish it? Oh
Wow. I kind of lost it. And so I'm like,
all right,
well what if I just did it for a month?
I think people could probably
pay attention for a month.
Then we'll really be interested for
a month before they really move on.
It's like all right,
month,
okay month and marathons and longest
month is 31 so I picked 31 and I have to
say when no,
you're doing,
you know what you're doing is hard when
you come on Jocko podcasts. And he says,
this is insane. Jocko Willink says
something is insane, you know, it's,
it's the right level of intensity.
So what kind of miles did you put into
get ready for it and how long did you
train for it?
Um,
my total a trained about 18
months for this specifically.
And I say that knowing that I had been
an athlete training just about twice a
day,
every day for five years at the time.
So I had that huge history of
being an athlete to begin with.
And then on top of that I put the 18
months of training specifically for this.
And so the way it would
work would be I would run,
I would do six week, a six
week block, uh, where, um,
where I was applying a certain stress.
And so my first six week block would be,
I was as basically just working
on getting long distance.
Cause when I was running triathlons I
only ever did, you know, five k Max.
So I would run an hour,
I'll probably run three times a week,
it'd be an hour or 90 minutes and another
hour and they'd be spaced out by a
couple of days.
So I do six weeks of that.
And then I would do a little test block
and my first test block was running the
Marine Corps marathon again.
So there's one marathon and then I do
another six week chunk where I would
change the stress and make it a
little bit harder. So I would do,
I would either run a little bit longer
on my really long run for the week or I
would block them together,
maybe like run an hour and a half
Wednesday and then run an hour Thursday,
kind of change up the,
the blocking.
And after that six weeks I would do
again and I would do two marathons.
And the first time I attempted
to marathons actually failed.
I didn't, I couldn't,
I ran the first one. The next day I ran
maybe half marathon and I, and I quit.
I was like,
okay.
Had you already said you were going to run
31 marathons? Yeah. At this point. Yeah.
That's reassuring. Yeah. All right.
But I kind of knew already
one or two, two, two.
Oh, I told my friends was like,
yeah, I tried to run to and I didn't,
they were like,
but what was it?
What was the failure based on?
Um, I didn't eat enough,
uh, the day before.
So the re part of the reason I was doing
these tasks blocks was figuring out
first of all, pacing, you know, good with
different at different ways to pace it.
Does that make sure I didn't blow up and
then figuring out how much I needed to
eat and figuring out, you know,
what it was going to feel like.
And so that first time I attempted to,
I didn't eat enough carbs, uh, the day,
uh, you know, after that first marathon,
so I was just totally depleted the next
day. So it was like, okay, I didn't,
it wasn't a lack of willpower or a
lack of kind of ability at that time.
It was just my approach
at that time wasn't, uh,
wasn't right. So I was like, okay,
I didn't really panic about that because
I knew I Kinda knew what happened.
And so like, all right. And so
I go and then I do six index,
kind of just repeated that
for the year and a half,
where six week chunk and I just change it,
block them together a little bit more,
run longer.
And then I tried three marathons and I
succeeded and it was pretty easy on an
easy, but you know, it's, I was
like, all right, just three. Yeah,
I don't feel that bad,
you know?
And then I did another six weeks and
changing the stress again longer and
blocked together more. I rent five
and I was like, all right, five. Okay.
And I would mess around with a different,
a different pacing strategies,
different ways of breaking up the Ma,
each marathon,
uh,
taking breaks and that kind of thing and
eating different foods just to see how
all that, I would react to that. And then
after five I was like, you know what,
I'm going to,
I'm not going to do any more than
five because if I do more than five,
I'm just going to want to keep going. I
don't really want to. So five is enough.
I felt really good after five.
And then after that I just kinda trained
through for maybe three more months,
but I kept every six weeks
I kept adding more mileage.
And so the last 12 weeks I was
running a marathon every Thursday.
And
how many total miles where
you putting in a week
and that lasts 12 weeks,
probably 60 like my, my,
you know how they say a dead
lifts starts at 135 pounds,
you know like my runs but
start at two hours, you know,
I wouldn't do anything less
than two hours. And then yeah,
I would do that marathon on Thursday
and I would run two hours the day before
and two hours of the day after.
And the reason I was doing that was this,
get this run a marathon.
So many times leading up to it that the
thought of running one marathon isn't
really, it's a norm.
It became normal to me.
And so I was trying to get that mental
to to run a marathon at the pace at your
sustained 31 day pace at my
sustained, it was interesting. So
we run in like eight minute miles,
nine minute miles.
Usually it would, it would be between
eight 30 and nine minute miles.
And it was interesting because in the
summertime I was running like a four and a
half hour marathon of total running time.
And so all the predictions I
put on my website was like, oh,
I'm probably going to finish in
about this amount of time. But I had,
that was during the hot and
humid summer in Virginia,
whereas when I was doing this,
it was in the fall time,
so I was actually able to run faster
and people would come out and say,
well that you,
yeah,
you said you're going to be running
like nine 10 minute marathon,
10 minute miles, then you run an
eight 30 or eight or nine minutes.
And it was kind of,
it was,
what else was interesting was I
figured my first marathon would be,
I'd be fresh and that'd be my fastest
marathon. And so that was in London.
It was about four hours roughly
of running time with breaks.
I would take three 20 minute breaks,
four hours of running time,
and then it Kinda did
follow that trajectory where
Philadelphia in New York and
Boston were a little bit slower,
like four oh five four
15 somewhere in there.
And then after I got there,
I actually started getting faster.
So the next all the way into Chicago,
my fastest one was my 10th one in
Chicago was three 50 and of running time.
And then after that it kind
of does level off and I'd be,
I'd usually be going somewhere
between three 50 and four hours.
The human body's amazing.
Yeah.
And all this stuff that I've been able
to adapt to and even I still wasn't able
to predict that I would actually
get faster. I didn't expect that.
And so I mean this goes to show you that
the body can adapt to even more than
you think.
What are the biggest challenges of regular
running and running with prosthetics
on? So yeah, one of the,
one of the things I had to figure out
was one of the things I learned and the,
my first and second Marine Corp Marathon
was that I needed to figure out how I
was going to prevent skin breakdown.
So prevent,
I would run after my first marathon I ran
and then I took my legs off and it was
this blood.
I'd like take the liner off and just
blood just shot everywhere and it wasn't
all blood, but it was like kind of blood
mixed with sweat. It was like, oh my God,
what did I do to myself? Did I,
I was, I was scared. I was like,
did I mess up my skin graft is that thing,
because those things can
be kind of sensitive.
And it ended up just being
a little blister like,
or a little lights bribed the skin off.
And that's like the size of that big.
But I knew if I did that ran again the
next day and that's going to get bigger
and that's going to totally
derail the whole thing.
So I had to figure out a way that I
could avoid getting like my skin rubbing
off.
And so I started messing around.
I wear these things called liner liners
that kind of wick the sweat that kind of
collect the sweat to,
to help with a claim Munis.
And so usually I'll put those on and they
would go all the way around the end of
my stump.
It'd be like a sock on the end.
So what I did was I cut
that off at the end.
And so it's kind of basically like a
kind of like a rash guard on my thigh and
it wouldn't go down to the end
of the stump. So I cut that off.
You want it to go down to the end. So
what my theory was, it's kind of a cloth,
it's a cloth material. So
what I figured was, and the,
and the liner itself is a silicone and
I didn't figure that the silicone would
be creating a whole lot of friction.
So what I figured was maybe that
little liner liner, you know,
as comfortable as it was, was it was
still fabric. So it was probably just,
you know, 40,000 steps still
rubbing the skin off. So, all right.
So I'll cut that off and see what happens.
And that was good,
but it still didn't fix everything.
So what I ended up doing was,
I just know from my cycling experience,
I'd use shammy cream on my, on your,
but you know, to help prevent
saddle sores. It's like,
well maybe I'll take the shammy cream
and put it on the spots that I know tend
to get rubbed. So I,
I would goop out loud,
just take a huge group and just
slather it on there. And uh,
and that seemed to fit, that fixed it
pretty good. And so I was like, all right,
so I figured that method out.
So that's one of the things is trying to
figure it with running with prosthetics
is figuring out how to
avoid that skin breakdown.
Um, and that's Kinda
Numero Uno cause that can,
I mean you can be as strong as you want,
but if your skin,
if you can't put your leg on
cause the skin hurts so much,
then all that strength that
doesn't, it doesn't matter. So,
so what'd you do with your diet
where you're just pounding calories?
I mean just eating everything in sight.
Yeah.
So I approached my diet a little bit
differently than most you might expect for
marathons. I did a low carb diet, well,
what would be a low car
for this kind of thing?
So I was using this in all my training
and all my pacing and all my eating.
I did this thing called the maffetone
method and it's basically this guy,
Phil maffetone figured that you should
do all your training at an a robotic
level. So he figured out this through
experience, he calculated your,
he came up with an equation to calculate
your maximum aerobic heart rate was 180
minus your age.
And then there's other little
adjustments you can make to that.
So my maffetone heart rate
was one 49 and so I see.
I'd never ran anything over one 49 you're
on a heart rate monitor all the time.
Yeah, I had a uh, Tom Tom Watch, uh,
and I had one and that my wife has one,
so I had to on when I was running my
marathon just in case one messed up.
And so I ran all,
I'm all my training and all my marathons
were run at as close to that one 49
heart rate. And what it does is trains,
instead of like making you strong,
your muscles stronger,
it actually trains your cardiovascular
efficiency. So when you start out,
you'll be running at one 49 heart
rate and you'll be pretty slow.
But as you do that more your heart
and lungs will become more and more
efficient. So eventually you'll be
running at that same one 49 heart rate,
but you'll be running twice
as fast. Right? Because it's
becoming more efficient.
So I just approached it like that or I,
I,
I kind of figured it'd be better to do
it that way because the more glycolysis
and the more carbohydrates you use,
the more your body's going to have to,
they're more destructive to
your body. So I'm like, well,
in order to be able to run these,
I have to run them at a maintainable pace
and in a, in a, in a maintainable way.
I can't just go out and run as
fast as I can. Every single one.
I had to pace it. And so I figured
that's how it was going to pace it. Uh,
keeping my heart rate under
one 50 not using those carbs.
And so that also allowed me to be
able to eat just really high fat.
Um,
I think I had between 150 and 175 grams
of carbs a day and that's what I limited
it to. And then I would eat, uh,
during the run I would eat
three bonk breaker bars.
I wanted each of my breaks and they're
just like these little energy bars and
that would keep me going.
That would be my kind of a lot of carbs
there so that we kind of keep me going
during the run. I would just drink
water whenever I got thirsty.
And then after I ran,
we had pre made these pre meet all my
meals and we just made this super calorie
dense cheese and meat sauce that'd be
froze and we put it all in the freezer and
it was just the densest,
you know,
the calorie dense this stuff you
could probably be like, you know,
whole containers and cream
and cheese and all this stuff.
So super dense and my mom would heat up a,
a bowl of that for me and I would take
a bag of pork rinds and put that in the
Chile and mix that in there.
And get the whole thing.
And a lot of the times before I,
before I even ran,
I would eat another bag of pork cracklings
so I'd have two bags of pork rinds,
his big ass bowl of meat
sauce and cheese sauce.
And then I would eat a sweet potato chips,
things like that.
If somebody brought us donuts,
I'd have a Donut, you know, uh,
if people as people could see
what just happened to Jocko was I
thought he was going to come
across. Um, so I'd eat that.
And then at the for dinner I'd eat a eggs
and bacon. And the whole time you're,
you got an RV cause cause you did
this in 31 different cities. Yeah.
You started off in London and then he
flew back to America and then started the
grind. New York, Chicago,
just going around the country.
And you a wife and a little
support team was in the RV.
Yup. So it was four of us. It was a Pam.
Like what kind of Rv did you have? Um,
coachmen Mirada, I think it's
like a 35. Do you have a RV?
30 to 35 footer, Huh? Yeah,
it was class eight 35 foot king size
bed in the back. Oh, that's nice.
Good.
And RVs know as long as you're not moving.
I don't know why I sleep like
a baby in RVs. I slept well,
but it's not totally comfortable when
you're driving down the highway at 60.
It's pretty bouncy back there.
And actually it made it,
this is something I didn't expect was
it made it kind of hard to eat being in
the back.
So I'd be,
I'd have to eat all this stuff and by
being in the back of that Rv for five,
six hours, I would start to
get a little bit my appetite,
we just going to go away more bouncy
than being in the front. Oh yeah.
Big Time behind the axle and
there's so much weight. Yeah.
Uh, yeah. So it'd be Pam,
my wife, team leader. Uh, she drove some,
she drove a lot. Uh, any, I wasn't even,
I wasn't really in charge of the were
just day to day. Yeah. My job was, yeah,
exactly. Well run when I
needed to run, when I need to
do interviews, run my mouth,
do that. And then that was it
pretty much. And then, but Pam,
she was doing everything,
you know, driving,
uh, setting up, scheduling
all my interviews,
working with these reporters and they're
like, oh, we want to do this at six 30.
Can we make that happen?
She's schedule it in and then
calling ahead to the venues
that we had decided to,
to run at, you know, squaring that away.
Okay, where can we park? We're coming now.
Um,
and there's probably so many other jobs
that I didn't even know about that she
was doing. Um, and then,
you know, it's taken on a,
a boat load of stress for
her. And then, um, my mom,
would she be kind of Pam's assistant,
she be in charge of kind of keeping
me fed and hydrated during when I was
running and making sure
I didn't need anything.
And then afterwards she
would make my meals.
And then one of her most important
jobs was, she's a massage therapist.
So she'd give me two massages
every day, uh, after I ran,
while we were driving to the next place.
And then I also had a driver who, uh,
who did most of the driving and then he,
uh,
he just kind of helped out
around the, uh, the RV.
Like whatever Pam needed him
to do something he would do it.
Or what kind of people
joined you on the runs?
I know you said you were
telling me yesterday some,
some Royal Marines in England. Oh yeah.
Joined you got it out there. I mean,
tons of military. Um,
if I had to categorize,
I mean it just people,
people from all walks of life and your
ultra runners would find out about it and
people that ran, people that didn't even
run would come out a lot of military.
Um, I would say 50% of the people
though that came out, I'd say,
how'd you hear about this? They
say, Jocko pocket, no bullshit. 50.
At least 50% of them. Um, the
troopers are not playing around.
They're doing major support. And then,
uh, he has to be a lot of millet.
A lot of guys that I deployed with
came out and supported a lot of cops,
a lot of fire departments.
Uh, but you know, it's, it,
there really wasn't one niche. It was
just even kids would come out. Yeah.
Kids would come out,
people with their parents,
a full families would come out for the
day and, and run. Um, it was awesome.
I had kids that ran their
first ever marathon with,
with me, you know, and a
lot of people would just,
they'd be running their first marathon
and then I had a white lady, she's like,
well, I'm running a marathon next week,
but I'm going to run one with you.
And she PB do, you know? And so
it'd be all, all sorts of people.
I'd come out of the RV in the morning
and they're just be people that had been
waiting there for me to
come out and no matter what.
And it didn't matter that morning.
Would you start running?
I would usually start around seven. Um,
unless I had some kind of big interview.
Like I had a Fox and friends
interview when I was in New York,
so I started at seven 30 or eight.
Uh,
but I would try and be pretty religious
about starting at seven and then, um,
yeah, people be out there. It didn't
matter if it was 20 degrees in Denver,
they'd be out there. If it was raining,
they'd be out there, you know, it was,
it was awesome.
That is awesome.
What was the,
what was the hardest part or did
you meet any hard parts during the,
during the trip I was there and actually
I remember when you were getting ready
to go. Yeah, this is pretty
cool. I'm like, hey man,
like one if you know what
if you're not gonna make it,
what if you can't?
And what I was actually thinking about,
I was thinking about your legs and,
and I know that, I mean I've, you know,
I've got other friends that, that they
have prosthetics and I know that it's a,
that it's a grind and
it rips your skin apart.
And I was kind of figured that's what I
was thinking. I wasn't thinking like, Oh,
you work is going to get tired and quit.
But I was thinking that there,
there might come a point
where you physically weren't
gonna be able to do this
without, you know, causing
massive damage to your body and,
and possibly, you know, getting infections
and everything else. And I said,
you know what, if, what if something
happens and you're like, no, I'm gonna,
I'm going to finish it. I was
like, okay, well there you have it.
Yeah. Well, you know, that was something
I was concerned about too. I didn't know,
uh,
how my body was gonna react to it and
I didn't know for sure.
I never knew even up to the last one,
the last mile,
the last one,
I would never have say I'm definitely
gonna Finish this because you know,
anything can happen.
Cause I could have my prosthetic on,
twist it a little bit,
and then that rubs off skin on my
skin graft and then that causes it to,
to die or something. And then I'm screwed.
And then I had, I can't, you know,
can't continue. Uh, so I never
knew for sure, but I've, I,
I believed that as long as everything
kind of went according to plan,
then it was possible as long as
no catastrophic events happen. Um,
and I was feeling confident.
I was very confident the whole time.
And then I got all the way around to
Texas and I had been really lucky with the
weather all the way around.
We got to Texas and we're hitting a
heat wave in Texas and it was probably,
I woke up in the morning and,
and uh, Houston sweating,
sweating already was ridiculous.
I was just covered in sweat.
Waking up in Houston. It
was like a hundred percent
humidity, probably like 75,
80 degrees just to start the
day. Houston gets on, Oh my God.
And he gets to me pretty easily.
It's,
it's the one thing like
a really slow me down,
but I came out of that RV and there were,
and the heat so the heat
can get to you because you,
you basically are missing a
couple radiators. Oh yeah. I mean,
cause you're your body,
everyone's body gives off a lot of heat
through their legs and you don't have
those radiators to give off
heat anymore. Yeah. So you, you,
you can overheat fairly quickly.
Exactly. Um, yeah. And then my am I,
so in addition to not
having the radiators,
my legs are in cased and carbon fiber,
so it's actually bottling in the
heat on my legs instead. So, uh,
it can really slow me down.
But I came out of that RV and Houston and
there was just 70 people
there waiting for me to run.
And a lot of them were marines.
There's a vocal,
a marine recruiting office that came
out and they brought their pool,
these people that were about
to go to bootcamp. Awesome.
And they brought them out. And I'm like,
well, it doesn't matter. You know, I,
I'm gonna, I'm not, even if they weren't
there, I still would've, you know, ran it.
Yeah. But I'm like, man, look at all
these people that want to run with me.
And so I just did it. And
then it just, it took a long,
I think that was probably my longest,
was probably four and a half hours of
a running and that was a guy in his
regular wheelchair that did
it with me the whole time,
just real and in his wheelchair behind
me. Um, so that was a really tough date.
So that San Antonio, Houston, Dallas,
we're all really hot and really humid
and I had to do back to back to back. Uh,
but I got through it because people came
out and ran with me and he like kept me
going. And um, and then in Nashville,
I,
it was,
it had been raining that day and I was
running on a trail and there were these
wooden bridges over these little creeks
and I had run on wooden British before,
so I knew they were going to be
slippery. And I was like, all right,
I'm going to take it slow over this.
And I still,
I slipped on this bridge
and injured my back.
Not at the time, it didn't feel like I
ended it at the time. I was like, hmm,
that's was kind of a hard fall.
And I kept running the next
day when I woke up in Atlanta,
my back was killing me and it was,
I had four left.
And um, I just had to
gut it out, you know,
every time I landed on my right foot is
like kind of shot up bad pain into my,
into my middle back.
And it was a little bit
frustrating because I was like,
I was feeling so good up to that point.
And I had run a super
fast marathon in Memphis.
I was feeling so good. I was like, Oh man,
I'm going to be able to really enjoy these
last four, you know? And then, you know,
the university is like, nope, you're
going to have to earn it. Sorry.
You're going to have to earn it.
It would
cruise these last four days. And then
you finished up on veteran's day? Yeah,
in, in DC, in DC veteran's day. Um,
and my back was fin a little
bit better at this point,
but still hurting pretty bad.
And it was interesting because
all up until that point, my,
my stumps were feeling pretty good.
They had,
I started to get these little pockets of
fluid on that kind of the outer corner
of both of them and they hurt,
um, when I pushed on them.
And then usually for the first
mile they would hurt pretty bad.
And it got to a point where my mom
had this like Kinda IcyHot spray.
She was spraying that on, on the
ends every day to help. And so,
but after the first mile,
that pain would kind of go away.
I would just pound them into submission
or whatever and they would be like,
all right,
you're just going to keep going.
We're just going to turn
ourselves off or whatever. And uh,
so after the first mile I'd be good and
they wouldn't really hurt it much more
until the next day. Yeah.
It's like he hears us,
he hears this, he's going to keep
doing it. Um, and yeah, and yeah,
so after the first mile would be,
they'd be fine,
but on that last day in Washington,
DC, they just never turned off.
And I think maybe it was because it was
that same thing where I knew this was
the last one in my body,
kind of knew what was the last one.
So it was starting to maybe let itself,
I would have held on to that last one
that maybe this is starting to let itself
unravel a little bit.
And so that whole last day
was just paint in the back,
freezing cold.
It was like 20 degrees out.
And so every time I stopped to rest
I was sweating. I was like, you know,
I had a hot water bottle.
I was all snuggled up with under a
blanket and I would still be like cold,
but just the sheer number of people
that were there. I never was. I,
there was never less than a hundred
people running with me that entire day.
It's awesome.
And I had,
there was people there that had run with
me and other cities that came and came
from the last one. I had brothers with
me that had deployed to Afghanistan. Uh,
all they're running with me.
Um,
I had for my last mile,
I had a,
there was a general running,
he was out in front,
so like were running around the
national mall in my last mile around the
reflecting pool was
that it's about a mile.
And so there was a general out
front and be like clear the way,
clear people out of the way,
you know.
And then there was a sergeant major
who had been my company first sergeant
rhythm.
So they were running like side by side,
no politely telling people
to get out of the way. Uh,
sergeant major Kent Retired
sergeant major of the Marine Corps,
top sergeant major in the Marine Corps
was running with me that last, uh,
maybe 12 k singing cadences, you know. Um,
there was, uh, you know, I just had, I had
brothers with me that were in the group,
uh, their kids, you know, uh, Pam joined
me for that last mile. My mom joined me.
I had family in there for the last mile.
And before we started that last
mile like gear I prom, it was like,
all right everybody,
I'm going to take this last mile
real slow just so that we can,
everybody can stay together. And then by
the end of them, I was like sprinting, but
just so pumped up, you know,
to be finished. But man,
it was so cool. And I've,
I, uh, finished that last little
loop and I kind of like ran up.
There's this little curved sidewalk
that goes up to the Lincoln Memorial.
And so I finished that last mile.
I kind of curve it up to that last,
and the whole sidewalk was lined with
folks and then they had set up a little,
a finish line for me up there.
And the whole thing was just lined
with people like, you know, and uh, uh,
cross a finish line. Pam was there,
you know, uh, we celebrated, she cried.
I did not cry,
uh,
to make that clear right now I'm
finished, you know, kissed her,
hugged her, and then the,
then the reporters Kinda came
in and started, uh, talking.
Awesome. And, uh, do you, you raise
money? Yeah. You raised money,
a bunch of money for the,
I know you support a bunch of foundations,
so that was awesome too.
That was sort of the other driving force
behind you doing it besides just you're
crazy, but also because you were raising
money for a bunch of good causes.
Yeah. You know, raising money, we raised
200,000, um, at the time I finished, I,
I kinda,
I stopped keeping track,
but it's probably like 215 now
or something like that. Uh,
for semper fi fund tunnel to towers
foundation coalition to suit America's
heroes.
And that was kind of
okay.
That was what,
that was kind of how I almost,
okay.
Uh,
manifested physically manifested
how successful that was.
And so my, what I was trying
to do is this, create that,
create a story that
people could feed off of.
And so
when you,
when you look at all the stories that
are out there about veterans coming back,
the vast, vast, vast,
vast majority of stories are
the post traumatic stress story.
Every movie that comes out
that is about OIF, OEF,
veteran coming home is
this pretty much the same.
Okay.
Uh,
same recipe veteran goes overseas,
they experienced war. They see
some bad stuff like you do in war.
They come back and there a basket case
and they implode and they implode their
family and all that stuff.
And
okay,
that's a good,
that's a hugely important story to
know cause it does happen and it's,
we have to take care of those guys and
we have to make sure we keep that story
in our,
in the forefront of our minds.
But what started to bother me was that
was the only story that was getting told.
And I think General Mattis said it best
when he answered the question somewhere.
And he said, you know, expectations
are very strong. So if you,
if you go overseas and everybody's
kind of expecting you to, uh,
basically have pts,
then there's a good chance that you're
going to manifest that in yourself just
by date, by virtue of the fact
that that's what's expected.
And so you can just going
to create that. Yeah. Um,
and so what I wanted to do
was get this story out there,
tell a story where there was
a guy that went overseas,
had a traumatic experience and came
back and was better than he was before.
And so that was how I determined I was
going to create this story and know I
felt that I knew that this was a problem,
that this story wasn't getting out there.
And also I felt the responsibility
to create it myself.
And you know,
if it's not out there,
it's like what I was saying in
that I can't a journal, you know,
I had that responsibility because
it just wasn't out there very much.
And so I set out to create that
story and then, you know, so if,
if there was a guy that was struggling,
um,
he could see that story and
then he could see, you know,
what it actually is possible to go
see war and come back and be fine and,
or not be necessarily be
totally fine, but, uh,
overcome it and find your new path and
find your new mission and continue on and
keep fighting for veterans. Keep fighting
for your brothers. And if they've,
if there's a guy that's coming
home and he's kind of on the fence,
he sees that story and maybe
take some of the the right way.
And then at the same time getting it out
there for civilians. Uh, there's, uh,
a major military civilian
gap of Understanding Cause
Military Taryn tends to be
isolated and on the
basis. And you know, that
I could see that gap because of all
these movies that were coming out.
There's every like 100% of movies that
came out were the main character at PTSD.
Whereas you look at the statistics and
it's 25% of non combat troops have what
we'll call PTSD,
7% of combat troops have PTSD.
And so it's a huge
misrepresentation of the actual,
uh,
of the actual scale.
And so I wanted to civilians
to see that story. Or here,
here's a veteran that came,
came home and was, you know, he,
he was able to kind of adapter process,
uh,
what he'd seen.
No, I think that's 100% right. And I think
you get, you get, you, you nailed it.
And Maddis nailed it.
Like you set the expectations that
everyone thinks that when they go to war,
they're going to be all screwed up.
It's like that's what's going to happen
to them. But if they, if they get told,
hey, and, and I mean you, you know, you
just, when you came home you were better.
Yeah. And like, that's
awesome. And, uh, you know, I,
I had that conversation with
Sam Harris where, you know,
I, he'd asked me, he said,
hey, you know, you, you get told you,
I hear you saying that war
is horrible and war is hell,
but at the same time you say that it was
like the best highlight of your life.
And it was, and I told him, and he's like,
how do you reconcile those two things?
And I said, well, have you ever
known someone that had cancer?
And when they get,
if they make it through,
they say it made him a better person
and it wouldn't wish it on anyone,
but it made him a better person.
And, and, and he said, yeah.
And it made sense to him then. And, and
that's what I think is important thing.
And, and you know, look at the, I mean,
every war has incredible veterans that
come home and do incredible things.
And I mean, Charlie plumb
when he was on, you know,
after being in the Hanoi
Hilton for six years,
and he rattled off the guys that were
in the Hanoi Hilton with him that were,
you know,
presidents and,
and congressmen and just all
these incredible achievements.
Maybe not presidents,
but incredible, incredible
achievements. Well, presidential,
a candidate with Stockdale,
so, and Ann Mccain, right?
Two presidential candidates.
So,
so incredible achievements.
And yet the,
the media and the Hollywood,
they don't shine the light on that. What
they shine the light on is the, the,
the people that are having issues, which
again, like you said, that's real too.
But the fact that you made this huge
effort and are continuing to make a huge
effort to show not just civilians,
but also military that yeah, wars
bad. I mean, you've, you know,
you say you had a traumatic experience,
you had a freaking life
changing experience, and
you've come back and you've,
you've proven that that traumatic
experience is not as strong as you are.
And I think that's the most
important message that,
that anyone could communicate
back to both sides,
both the civilian and military side.
Yeah.
And I mean,
there's so much to be said about what
knowing something is already possible.
So I told you about Dan Kinison last time
I was here and back then he was about
a year and a half in front of me and he
was showing me what was possible for me.
I didn't know that it was possible to
be able to walk around and with a huge
backpack on and using no canes.
But once I saw it, it's like, oh,
so it is bottle.
And it just made it so much easier to do.
And I was doing a talk not too long ago
and somebody told me afterwards that
something that I didn't even
realize. Um, I was, you know,
how last time I was talking about,
uh,
finding ideas and that we do that thing
called proof the lane and they told me
that they just kind of mentioned
to me that I kind of had continued.
I did in the Marine Corps and I,
I did this thing called proofing the lane
where I was proving what, what I was,
you know, stepping on the
ground and proving was cleared.
And then they said that kind of that
I didn't realize that this is a time,
but they said that theme is
following you wherever you go.
So I'm now proofing the lane for these,
these veterans that maybe struggling a
little bit trying to improving what's
possible. And so, yeah,
I'm glad that they, uh,
glad that they told me that because
that really makes a lot sense.
That makes total sense. Then Dan
can Austin, who's a total stud,
he's about to be in the parallel again.
Yeah. Again, he's going to up
Yon. Was it Xiang Wisconsin?
Yeah.
Pyong Chang a South Korea to a,
I think he's doing biathlon and uh,
the cross country skiing.
Yeah. No, he's a total
beast, uh, seal, uh, that,
that also lost both of his legs above
the knee and just a total bad ass stud.
Um,
I want to read a couple more
little sections from your
journal to close this out
here. We go back to the journal.
So when I get asked by people,
how could you fathom let alone complete
running 31 marathons in 31 days?
I give them the same simple answer because
I am a marine and my mission to fight
for my fellow veterans has not changed.
And when a Marine is on
mission for his fellow marines,
he is capable of anything.
Therefore, when people asked me,
haven't you done enough,
sacrificed enough,
I remind them that not only do I have
the capability to accomplish my mission,
be proud of my Marine Corps heritage,
stay faithful to my fellow
marines and keep fighting.
I have the responsibility,
I have the responsibility to keep
fighting for my country, my core,
and my fellow veterans. So
no, it will never be enough.
The day that I have done enough will be
the day that six marines lower my body
into my grave in Arlington Cemetery.
And how can I do it?
I do it because it is my duty
and to do my duty is my honor.
In one last little passage I
want to read from your journal,
it says,
I am merely a representative of
what is possible for any veteran,
any person.
So as time passes,
I do not want my name to be remembered.
All I want to be remembered is the story
years from now when people speak about
this,
I want them to say,
I remember that guy who ran all those
marathons that one time and their friend
will, will reply, what was
his name? And they will say,
I don't remember,
but he was a marine.
Well
Rob, I can tell you that, uh,
I got a feeling that you
will be remembered and your
name will be remembered and
the way that you have represented the
marines and America and mankind will be
remembered
and remembered and revered as well.
So
thanks for coming on the show again and
letting us all know that we are capable
of much,
much more
if we just step up and
push a little bit harder.
Okay.
Been awesome having you back on man. It's
been awesome being here. I mean, again,
I'm glad I could come up
with, uh, the material.
I was like, why don't you just say
you invited me back. I was like,
I got our start writing.
So
stop. No, you don't have to. Right.
You got any questions for the
man? Yeah, he, was there any time,
like during the 31 marathons that you
were like, oh, this is kind of lame
gob kind of off this? No. Were you
ever, did you ever think that, I mean,
not even necessarily that you were
like tired physically or nothing,
just kind of like, you know, it's kind of
Tristan, we got, I got, I definitely got
tired of doing the interviews. Oh, okay.
Yeah. Yeah. But the thing with
that is the interviews, you know,
I didn't, I wasn't doing this to
like to get a bunch of, you know,
people telling me I'm awesome or
anything. Um, but the interviews,
so doing the marathons without the
interviews would be pointless because the
story wouldn't get out there
without doing the interviews.
But doing the interviews
without the story,
without doing the marathons is actually
is also a point where I kind of got
there.
The funny thing is
I did this because it
was going to be hard.
I did this because it'd be
really difficult. Yeah. Yeah.
And I knew that going in and that's the
whole purpose of it is to do something
that was hard. And then, you know, the
last four days and then Houston and stuff,
when it started to get
hard, I was like, well shit,
was it so hard?
But um,
okay.
Yeah, I like I, like I was saying before,
there was never a point where I was like,
there's no way I can do this or
anything like that. I was like,
as long as I don't get
severely injured by a mistake,
don't get hit by a car or you know,
break a bone or something,
then I'm going to be able to do this.
Yeah. Going to get her done.
Yeah. I feel like the air,
like every once in a while when I
do something that takes a long time,
like months or something like that,
I get to a point everyone every once
in a while and I'm like, what am,
what am I doing here?
Yeah, it's definitely good. It
just, it gets repetitive for sure.
Wake up a run the marathon. You don't
listen to music, you don't listen to,
do you listen to podcasts?
Do you listen to music?
Did it really on the month of marathons?
Except a few times because
I had people with me and be like, Hey, I'm
listening to a podcast. Leave me alone.
You know, sometimes I didn't
do that to be honest with you.
There were times I did do that. Um,
sometimes that Wednesday morning,
that Jocko podcast,
um,
you're hoping for a long one.
One of the few people I was
hoping for a four hour podcast
were,
I felt kind of bad in the last four
because I told you my back was hurting so
much and it was like every time I land
on that right foot would be severe pain
and then I would kind of make me
like kind of gasp a little bit.
And so I felt really bad because there's
a lot of people that were, you know,
they came out to run with me and they
were like talking to me and trying to try
and help me keep going. But I just was
not in the mood for talking, you know?
And I felt terrible because they be like,
ask me questions.
I'd be like giving him the one word,
you know, like, Oh, you know, they,
but what's your favorite
place? Or whatever. I'm
like, oh, I don't know. Yeah.
And it's,
I just,
so I wish I could have handled
that part a little bit better.
And you know, get let those people who
I talked to, those people who have it,
but I'm sure they understand why.
And I kind of said it before and I'm like,
listen to everybody.
Yeah. If I'm not talking,
if it's cause I have this back injury
and it's not because I don't like yes,
because I hate you. Yeah.
So it's that. But you know,
when, when it got hard, uh, I fell
back on, on my mission and uh,
that's what, uh, that's what
I was doing it for. It didn't,
whether or not I was hurting or didn't
feel like doing it was not as important.
Anything to do with anything really.
Does it vary?
I ask you,
I want to ask your opinion on something
cause I came up with a theory and it's
not totally thought out yet like this
and this theory might actually get me
killed. So please echo, uh, defend to me.
I think that there may be something
that's more powerful than discipline
and what
anybody that's listening
Jocko reached for the night.
And, and maybe it's just that
they're kind of go hand in hand.
But I think the one thing that may be as
powerful or maybe even more power from
the discipline is a selflessness.
And so the reason I say that is because,
I don't know,
maybe the discipline leads to the
ability to perform the selfless act.
But it seems to me like
all the discipline in the world might
not allow you to do something like lift a
car
off of your child, you know, r
or dive on a grenade. Well, yeah,
I mean there's, I think you're actually
100% right on. That's a theory.
I think that, you know, when you
take guys in combat, we, when,
when guys are in combat and
guys do incredible things
and sacrifice their lives
for their brothers, that that is not
about discipline and the, you know,
they're doing that because
they're selfless and they
want to take care of their
friends. That's what they're
doing it for. And you know,
there can be people that are,
you know,
undisciplined individuals that perform
incredibly heroic things in combat.
So, no, I don't think, I don't
think it's a, I don't think it's a,
I think that's actually correct.
I mean, I think there's,
that's an extremely powerful
force. And, and you know,
that may be the end.
And I was thinking about,
you know,
the power of that where I thought you
were going to say when I thought you were
going to talk about it was you know, you
weren't doing this for yourself, right?
You know,
you weren't doing this for yourself.
You are doing this to get a message out
there that you're doing this to raise
money for others, for your friends,
for you to brothers. That's,
that is a more powerful thing than,
hey,
I'm just a self disciplined person right
now. You know, discipline is, is like a,
it's like there, it's like
they're, they're indifferent. Um,
it's not apples to apples. I
don't think. It's not like,
it's not like this is more
powerful than that. No,
because I'll tell you that
if you want to perform well,
if you want to achieve things,
like you wouldn't be able
to do this for these causes.
If you didn't have the
discipline to train, hard to
eat, right, to get on the path,
to stay on the path,
you wouldn't have been able to do
this even though you really wanted to,
even though you really,
really wanted to, you really,
really wanted to care about your brothers.
You really,
really wanted to raise money for those
funds if you have the discipline to make
it happen and,
and train yourself and be ready that,
that you wouldn't have been able to
deliver that just like a guy on the
battlefield there on the
battlefield because they,
they were able to perform the,
were able to have the discipline to get
to that point. Uh, but there, there too,
I'd say they're related.
I don't think they're,
they're definitely not
opposing each other. And I,
and in fact I think that if
I was to tell you, you know,
when I was in the seal teams w the dry,
the actual driving force
behind the discipline that,
that I tried to have myself wasn't for me.
It was like I want to be able to
perform well on the battlefield,
not because I want to perform well,
but because I want to make sure
I don't let my brothers down.
So I would say it's actually like a
force that's a foundational force.
You know, it's like people that
are heavily, heavily religious,
their discipline relies
on their religious faith.
People that are overachievers,
that want to accomplish something that
their discipline is based on the fact
that they want to get that achievement.
So the discipline by itself,
there has to be that the discipline,
there has to be a foundation that that's
built upon it. And I think a lot of,
a lot of times people build their,
their foundation of discipline,
the foundation that their discipline is
built on is actually the fact that they
want to take care of their friends.
They want to be able to
take care of their brothers.
I want to take care of their family. You
know, you get all kinds of, you know,
I was, you take a a single mom
that's working three jobs right now.
Well, she's has to be highly disciplined.
She has to be highly disciplined.
She's got to get up every morning at
three o'clock to get to the diner and time
to start waiting tables. She's
doing that. She has that discipline,
not based on the fact that she
wants to be stronger for herself.
She's doing that so she can feed her kids.
She's doing that.
She's doing that selflessly so that she
can feed her kids. So no, I mean that's,
uh, that's absolutely true. And
I totally agree. Warning. Yeah.
Supporting, uh, yeah. I
think the, the best way,
the way to get the most
out of yourself as a,
figure out a way to make it about
something that you care about more than
yourself. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
I think that discipline
is a manifestation of,
of selflessness in many ways. It's
a way that you're, like I said,
a single mom that's working
three jobs. Look, let's face it.
She doesn't want to work
any of those three jobs.
She doesn't want to work any of
those three jobs. But she's doing it.
She's doing it every day, day in, day out,
day out. Why you should do in that she,
why is she dismissed
showing that discipline and
manifesting that discipline.
It's because she cares about her kids
more than she cares about herself.
And that's all there is to it.
And you could go to the battlefield and
say the same thing. Well why do, why do,
why do marines train so hard? Why do,
why do we train hard in the seal teams?
Why are we doing that? Oh,
we doing that for ourselves.
Are we imposing that discipline ourselves?
Are we having the self discipline?
Because we want to be good for ourselves.
No,
it's because we want to be able
to take care of our friends.
We want to be ale to take
care of our brothers.
And you could go across the
board with any of that. So I,
I totally agree with you. Awesome.
Long, glad I'm still alive. No
Shit.
Could they at any point come into
conflict with each other where you got to
choose to remain disciplined
or serve others? I don't.
I don't see how they would
come in conflict with each
other and if they did come
in conflict, I think you make a rational
decision, you know, like, I mean,
I mean, Hey, am I going to
get sneak my workout in?
Like what's more important
to me working out or,
or going on a mission with my
friends. Right, right. Or your,
I dunno daughters piano recital
that they want you to be at,
but you gotta you know,
it's like you got it.
You got to choose between what and what
being disciplined with a workout that
day. Okay. I be making the recital. I mean
obviously you want to make the recital,
but if the,
if the choice was between making the
recital and you have to go to your job and
work well, if you don't go to
your job and work, guess what?
Now you don't have money to pay for
your piano lessons in the first place to
think about that, that all I'm
saying that this is a situation where
it discipline and selflessness
will come into conflict.
I'm just saying usually they're,
they support each other and
for sure I think you're right.
But is there a circumstance
where you're saying there is,
you could actually become,
you could actually focus on
yourself and be like, hey,
it's more important for me
to take care of me, right.
Than it is for me to take care of my
team and that's not going to go over well
with the team and we may end up being,
you know, a highly disciplined individual,
right. You, you have no,
you have no outlet for it because you
have no one to take care of it except for
yourself. And that's the thing, like
you see like the what's, what's the, uh,
I haven't watched the movie, but
I know exactly. No, I'm serious.
I haven't watched the movie.
It's American psycho, right? No,
I haven't watched the movie,
but I know exactly what the story is.
The guy is like super highly disciplined.
Right?
Isn't he like the way he does everything.
Highly disciplined,
but at the same time,
obviously he's a psycho and he's,
he's not supporting anyone but himself.
Sure.
So that's like an extreme version of
someone that cares about themselves. Yeah.
The sure they're highly disciplined,
but you know,
being highly disciplined doesn't
make you a good person. Yeah.
It doesn't automatically
make you it. Well, yeah,
it doesn't make you selfless and it
certainly doesn't make you a good person
either. And you could certainly get
into a situation where, you know,
you get people that are a bank
robbers. No, I was highly disciplined.
Bank robber. I wasn't thinking
bank robbers. But you think,
you know the people that are so into
working out that that trumps, yeah.
Family trumps everything and they,
and they have an issue, right.
They're so into it that they, that
they sacrifice, not even sacrifice.
They just don't care.
It's a w w you know,
when you meet someone that's so
into working out that, I mean,
that's a very selfish thing,
right.
Working out as a selfish thing right now.
There's part of it that selfless because
you're working out so that you can stay
healthy so you can take care of your
family, you can take care of front.
It's like we just talked about.
You can take that to a point. Yeah.
So you're capable of surviving and
taking care of your life, your friends,
your family. But you can easily
get to a point where, hey,
the most important thing
is me. Yeah. My pull up,
the most important thing is me and
my, my numbers. Yeah. My numbers.
And you know what,
I was danger close to this with
Jujitsu cause for awhile I was like,
I'd come home at night and my and my
wife would be like, you know, this is,
I was still in the teams and I was,
that was a task unit commander. Like we,
I was the, that was the most
important thing in my life.
But I would still come home at night at
seven 30 at night or eight o'clock at
night and I'd grab my gym bag and I'd
go train Jiu Jitsu and my wife would be
like, what the Hell is wrong with
you? It's like what are you doing?
And that's, that was borderline,
right? That was borderline.
But for me it was like,
Hey,
this is a skillset that I should have
when I'm on a battlefield so I can take
care of myself and take care
of my friends. And by the way,
that means I have a 1.001% chance that
I'm going to come home instead of not
come home.
So I'm going to do it.
And that right there,
that's probably a little bit of
raw rationalization cause cause,
cause selfish the, I really love training
Jujitsu. Yeah. Right. Yeah. So there's,
there's a selfishness there.
And I then I just tried to rationalize
a little bit and, and you know,
another thing we talked,
we talked about the first podcast with
you is rationalization and how you've got
to be careful of that. You
gotta be careful of rational
rationalizing everything.
So yeah, those are,
those are things that uh,
definitely can get, can become,
can become problematic if you,
if, well, that's, you know what,
that's why there's a dichotomy.
That's why there's a dichotomy and
everything cause you can go overboard with
any,
any personality trait you
can go too far with and the,
you can definitely go that. That's
why I discipline and freedom. It's,
it's actually a balance. Even though
discipline equals freedom. But guess what?
If you have pure discipline,
if you remove all freedom,
well then what did you just do in
sleeve? Yeah, you enslaved so you,
there's balance, there's
balance in, in discipline.
There has to be balanced in discipline.
I think the reason that it strikes
people to talk about discipline equals
freedom is because most people
don't make that connection.
And most people lean so far towards
just freedom of doing whatever they want
that they ended up in, slaved from a
different direction, which is equally,
if not more problematic.
And I say more problematic because now
you're in a situation where you're slaves,
you're enslaved by something that's
not good. That's not healthy,
that's not positive.
Whereas at least with discipline,
if you're s imposing the discipline
on yourself, self-discipline,
well then you're,
you're imposing things on you that or at
least positive long term, at a minimum,
they're positive long term. Yeah. Yeah.
Now, can you go overboard with that? Yes.
There's people that have eating disorders,
right?
There's people that have eating disorders.
They,
they impose such strict discipline
that they're unhealthy and that's bad.
And that's horrible. You know, I've, I've,
I've heard back from some people
that that said, hey, you know,
I have trouble with eating disorders.
You know,
it's generally been females who have
more trouble with that category and they
actually have to use the
discipline to say the Dick Correct.
Discipline thing to do is to eat more,
is to eat the proper amount of calories
because it's a horrible, horrible thing.
If you see people going through that
and it's a fatal disease, right?
It's a fatal disease. And so, so
again, to your point, there's,
you can become so disciplined that it's,
that it's negative,
it's negative on your personal health.
It's negative on your, you know,
you can work yourself,
you can work yourself so hard,
you can say I'm going to be disciplined
at work and now you, you stop,
you lose the balance and you start
stop working out and you stop training.
You start eating donuts and
you start eating donuts.
Not before you run a marathon,
but before you sit down in your
front of your computer. So they're,
there absolutely has to be balanced.
But
factually the,
the tendency,
the tendency is I'm going to be,
I'm going to be less disciplined
and when to do things that are easy,
I'm and been the easy path.
And that leads to, that's,
that's the 80% 90% I
don't know what percent,
but that is a vast majority of people.
Vast majority of people don't need
less discipline in their lives.
They need more discipline. That's the
vast majority of people, myself included,
myself and good need more
discipline, not less. Yeah.
And it's almost about what you're being
disciplined towards. So like in the,
the situation,
bring up with a recital,
you have the competing thing.
So maybe it actually takes more discipline
to forgo your workout and realize,
oh yeah, bigger picture kind of thing.
People will say to me, like on a,
on Twitter, they'll say, if
you have real discipline,
once you have the discipline
to sleep in tomorrow,
10 get out of your comfort
zone and sleep in. But yes,
so you'd have to look at the bigger, is
there a bigger discipline then? Right,
because you gotta you gotta you gotta
consider your goals and stuff like that.
You can't have the discipline to sleep
in if that doesn't benefit your goal.
Right.
It's not even discipline and like the
person that's struggling with the eating
disorder, they're discipline. At first
they were disciplined to lose weight.
I need to change that discipline to be a
healthy. Right. Consider the goal. Yeah.
The goal. The goal needs to change
the goal. What a scary thing.
It's a scary thing. You look in
the mirror and you, you, you,
you think you're
overweight and you're not.
Some guys get that the opposite for sure.
The body, this body body Dysmorphia,
morphine, is that what it's called?
Yeah. So you can have it like you know,
you think you're always, you always
think you're fat, but you're skinny.
And then the other way is like you always
think you're skinny so you need bigger
muscles. So you see that you get
on the juice. Yeah, whatever. Yeah.
Asteroids and that's what actually
why we're getting the Echo Jocko.
We'd like listening or we talked
about this earlier, too much muscles.
Your muscles are so supportive, man.
Juicing and before we
started cutting weight
shit,
speaking of health and support
and support Echo Charles,
is there any way that you
could advise us how to support
ourselves, ourselves and each other
and possibly we just support you.
Support we support,
we support.
We did actually one of the benefits of
having you on as you're very supportive,
that encouraging, you
know, and I like that.
But in the event of people,
US wanting to support this podcast in
addition to each other in addition to
ourselves or all at once,
we can stay on Jocko Super Krill oil.
I thought I going to say the path or
the path. That's bigger picture for
sure. And we'll talk about that.
But one of the methods to
stay on the path is Krill oil.
You can lift a lot of weight to get
strong muscles. Kind of like, um,
like when you tear your skin
apart I guess. But if your
joints are all jacked up,
they don't want to move,
you're not lifting nothing. So,
and this goes for everyday life. So
Super Krill oil, Jocko has supplements.
Finally,
super crew oil,
joint warfare and discipline,
which is a pre mission.
When he cognitive
enhancer force multiplier.
Technically what is force multiplier mean
is like when you get one thing Jen and
other and the sum is worth more than the,
than the parts kind of yet cognitive,
you're so excited about that.
I'm just going to let it roll
anyway. Three supplements, right?
Not counting the new one
that's going to come out soon.
So krill oil for your joints.
Joint warfare for fair for your
joints and discipline. Pre mission.
You take it, cognitive enhancers,
little bit of caffeine in there,
puts 15 milligrams unless you
drink multiple scoop. Sure.
Then it's 30 did an event the other
night and I was kinda tired going into it
straight up. I was kind of tired and,
and usually my events are during the day,
but this was at night as I
was kind of like, you know,
I had flown out there and I
was feeling a little bit site,
so I drank some discipline and then I
drank some more discipline and I ended up
having,
uh,
I guess it was a total sum total of
about five scoops of disciplines.
Sure. Too much discipline
in this guy, 60 milligrams,
but there's not just the
ballot. Yeah. But anyways,
I got done with the event and Gwen up to,
you know,
hung out with everyone for a little bit
added little dinner thing and then got
done with that and then hung out and
then went up to my room hotel room.
And I just sat there like PTF.
And the funny thing is I didn't
realize, I was like, why?
Cause I had gotten up early in the
morning. I worked out the travel,
the Bumblebee and I didn't realize why
am I, why do I have energy right now?
Why can't I sleep right now? This
is ridiculous. What's wrong with me?
What's wrong with me? What's wrong with
it? What's wrong with me? And then,
and then I didn't even
realize it until the next day,
cause I went to bed at
one 30 in the morning,
woke up at four 30 and then I
did like a stretch, came home,
Jack Steele. When I got home,
of course I got home, did score,
which is nice cause my arm's been
jacked up so I haven't been able to do,
I still, I'm not doing overhead
squats right now or even front squats.
I am doing front squats with a Kettlebell.
Yeah.
Just have a bigger kettlebell
than other people, but whatever.
Sure. So you gotta be
careful. Don't have the,
if you're not used to caffeine,
because I'm not used to caffeine
because I only have Jocko white tea,
which has the same 15
milligrams or discipline.
If you're not used to caffeine,
that little 15 milligrams and you drink
a bunch of it, you're going to feel it.
Don't drink it before you go to bed
at night. Yeah. That's my warning.
Unless you have stuff to do and let's get
stuff to do. Yeah, yeah. Get after it.
Yeah. Yeah. You want to balance the
discipline for sure. Yeah. You will not.
You will feel sharp. That's what's
good about it. You feel sharp. Good.
It's funny as and mentally when
you, or when someone says, boy,
I'm drinking the discipline you ever
watched? Spaceballs peaceful. I want,
he's like liquid shorts.
I can't remember.
It's like the shorts is the force
liquid force he spells is right. Yeah.
It was a parody of star wars. The
force. It's this shorts, right?
Just put it was shorts and
then he had the liquid Schwartz
or saw, I forget. Anyway,
that's how you sound when you say I'm
drinking the discipline. You can't drink.
You know? You see what I'm saying? Yeah.
I think you meant to do that. Nonetheless.
You get this@originmain.com
on the top it says,
labs actually emailed me. He
was like, Hey, I can't find the,
I can't find the discipline. I said,
look within yourself, Dan. I said,
the origin may not come on the top.
It says labs made like, you know,
I'm jumping back and forth. Anyway, that's
where you get it or didn't mean.com.
I'm also an origin main.com they've got
some cool geese all made in America.
Rash guards, compression gear tops
and bottoms. Rash guards, spats,
spats, spats. Do they have the black
out yet? I don't have to do all right.
You know, also look at the start
planning your schedule for the origin,
Jujitsu camp immersion. Immersion
camp. Yeah. It's not like,
it's not like a hardcore, like that's
the thing and that's what Pete kind of,
what world is what he was kind of
telling me where it's not like,
it's not like like boot camp or something.
Which would be cool too.
It's not like a training camp for like
an event. You know what I'm saying?
Like you don't want guys, yeah, yeah.
We're training. We're training hard,
but it's more like you're in there
to immerse yourself in Jujitsu.
You want to train hard, you train hard,
you want to learn hard. Yeah. Well, yeah.
The case in point, there's a lot of people
that have never even trained before.
They literally have never trained
before. Got Up and said, hey,
before this morning's class,
I need to get a g g,
you know? So yeah, that's an August.
You can check on the website
for that to come on up.
Echo Charles and I will be there. You
want to go? Yeah. Okay, cool. Come on.
It's like this cool cat.
Yeah,
you can start learning more than I taught
you last time we did. You did, sir.
I have Jiu Jitsu legs now. Oh you
do? What are they looking at you?
Because I told you you got to
get rid of like the hard thing.
Yeah. They were just that hard
sockets. Right. And so what I did was,
you know, had I had trouble standing up.
Yeah. So what I did was I had these two,
I have the sockets and go on my legs.
So what I had my process do its cover
them and foam and then so that's a little
bit softer for people.
So I don't hurt anybody.
And then he made it so I could just
stand on the ends of those sockets,
like the same height, the same height.
Awesome. And so now I have to kind of,
I use them to you. Uh, I haven't
started taking Jujitsu, uh,
cause I've been really busy. But uh,
I'm going to, I think once we get back,
my wife and I are going to start going in.
Awesome.
And then I also use them to
do some weightlifting stuff.
I've been able to figure out how
to do squats off the ground squats
and uh, yeah. So it's
awesome. So I'll be ready.
Yeah, no that, that is awesome. Yeah.
Cause the biggest concern
I had last time was the uh,
the shell had like a Leica and
metal valve and that thing was on.
Cool.
Oh yeah.
Jeremy,
I didn't realize at the time that you
were insulting me because that's how I do
not, no, not until after, uh,
cause the whole time you were after
we rolled, you were like, oh yeah,
you're really strong, really strong.
And then a couple of times later,
it's a couple of podcasts
later, you're like, oh, it's
actually an insult. It's the,
yeah, you don't have any technique,
but you're strong. You know,
I learned that was almost optimistic
to a fault was that when we roll,
and you've talked about this
before, when we roll, I was like,
there's gotta be a way
that I can catch Jocko.
There's gotta be some way in
that guy who was the guy, uh,
that's missing his hand that we rolled
with. I rolled with afterwards. Yeah.
Jeffrey. I had him in, I had him by
the neck and I was like, Oh Dang.
I got him. I can't believe I was like,
got him. And then afterwards he's like,
there's no possible way
somehow is this still optimistic
about what I can do to a fault?
Is that, and you're the, uh,
you're with so many people,
majority of people, especially in the
fall, in that category of like, well,
and the other funny thing is you'll get
somebody with something and then they
think to themselves, if I could,
if I just stopped that. Yeah,
they don't want to be able to,
when I had a, I had a wrestler,
this was back in the day,
I was like a blue belt and,
and this blue belt and I was going against
this wrestler, uh, you know, like a,
a really good college wrestler and the
look on his face every single time was
just, okay, let's, let's
go, let's go again.
He was the first person that I realized
that that's the normal reaction.
But especially for a wrestler because
rest of that wrestling college man,
they've been dominating
people in high school.
They'd been dominating people in College.
They know,
they understand grappling and so when
they get, they get like submitted,
they just can't,
they just don't even understand it.
It seems like the one thing they
worked on before and you know, and,
and I don't know. You can, you can,
you can give me some advice on this.
Is it better because
I've done it both ways.
Is it better to submit them with
the same thing every single time,
which I've done that or to submit them
so with something new every single time
where they just are dumbfounded.
Yeah. I think the second one gets,
especially given what you said,
because it's true, the wrestler,
he's going to have all this knowledge
of grappling so, and it makes sense,
you know? So you see this one weird
thing that you'd ever seen in your mind.
You're like,
all
right, that's weird. Kind of rare kind
of thing. It's the feeling and then,
but if you're like this thing, this
thing, this, and then it's like, okay,
this world is opening up now
on, okay, I understand. Yes.
It wasn't just that one thing, like
how you said it, that one thing,
I just got to stay away from
his or putting my neck and
I just stay away from it.
So it kind of or,
or deviates from that whole idea.
So we'll be having these discussions
and many more at the immersion camp in
Maine in August.
August,
right before school starts. Yeah. So yeah,
those are good fun anyway. Yeah.
Origin main dot. Come check it out.
Good way to support.
Also,
Jack talked about his new cool kettle
bell that's heavier than my nonetheless.
I got the whole set on, you know, you
know what Taylor I'm talking about, right?
Or the,
the primal belts,
whatever is I think is like a
cyclops in there too. Anyway.
Anymore word on the Jocko head
or is that that happen yet.
Still work in progress. The idea phase
on. I'm still, but yeah, that was good.
But nonetheless you want the whole set.
Put a on it.com/jocko really good kettle
bells in their other exercise stuff on
there too. You want to switch up your
workout. I ran into that the other day.
I'm like, Dang, this
workout is getting boring.
So like just BTF through it and
did, did you, cause it's good to,
to do things and you
brought this up before eve,
you're not used to something even
though it's like we talked about squats,
like going all the way down,
which is what I'm used to.
If I was to do squats to what
does it parallels of the deck,
this the standard. Yeah, the standard.
Then those squats would actually be
a little bit harder for me. Yeah.
For like a week or two weeks.
And then I'd realize that going down in
the hole is the place where you could
get, but, and it goes along with exactly
what you were saying, how like your,
your brain has to do is called
neuromuscular connection,
where if you're used to
doing a certain motion,
you can do it way more efficiently,
putting more weight on there.
And we're pretty efficient,
you know,
and that's what gain
where gains come from or,
or a big part of where it gains
come from. Um, so yeah, you just,
you just change the movement just a
little bit. Boom. Whole nother thing.
Your body got to get used to more
gains to be had. Well that's the whole
theory of Westside barbell is,
and they change their,
the way they do something every
three weeks, they either, yeah.
Instead of doing this bench press the
same exact way that they did that for
three weeks and then in the
next three weeks they do it.
Why do they do it with
a different kind of bar?
They do it different range of motion.
So once you,
they don't allow their buy to totally
adapt to the constantly changing.
Yeah. Yeah. Is Pretty,
there's a lot of cool ways you can
kind of manipulate that from workout to
workout. But yeah. Well that's so yeah.
If you want to vary up your workout with
all kinds of different movements on it,
they have some cool stuff. Battled
Macy's or no battle ropes, Macy's,
some other stuff on it. Dotcom
slash jungle, good spot. Also,
when you buy the books that we
sometimes review on this podcast, um,
I got them all organized on Jocko,
podcast.com in the book section.
Click, just click through
there. It takes you to Amazon.
Amazon prime if you have it and uh, you
know, get your book, good way to support.
If you do another shopping,
continue do your shopping,
buy that lawnmower you've
been meaning to buy.
Also subscribed to the podcast if you
haven't already. It seems obvious.
I know iTunes, stitcher, Google play,
Spotify and other podcasting
providing podcast,
providing platforms also in youtube
cause we do have a youtube channel.
Rob Jones, I know you're
on there. Sometimes
we have excerpts.
I think that's really one of the main
values is the excerpts of first podcasts
for sure.
Because yeah cause a lot of times,
I mean aside from seeing what you
and our guests look like, you know,
live video version of
whatever the excerpts are
shareable and I didn't realize
how valuable that was with the sharing
until when I think it's a gradually
increasing understanding of
the value overall. Nonetheless,
I could go into a whole thing about like,
hey could you make an answer to this
and make an extra for this and make it,
you're just starting to realize that the,
maybe they had a reason for that.
We'll just say I'm realizing it more.
How about that check nonetheless,
good value there in my opinion,
and a good way to support.
Still subscribe to the Youtube
Channel if you want. Also,
Jack was a store. If you didn't know
already, it's called Jocko store.
Go to [inaudible] store.com and if you
want the shirts that say discipline
equals freedom,
get after it.
The warrior kid shirt like this or they
should that Jack always aware as the
victory, MMA and fitness,
that's where he can get it.
That's where you get chocolate store.com.
We need to make grey ones of these
gray. Just gray. Heather Gray.
I don't care. I don't know
what gray gray can we do that,
but that's a general term. You know
gray. It's like you can't just say, hey,
you know you gotta. I need three shirts
for that summertime that's coming.
You got it.
There are 50 different shades of gray.
There's a whole [inaudible] right?
This guy doesn't know
you're talking about either.
That's the funniest pop culture reference.
Yeah, 50 shades of grey. I know.
Nonetheless,
I'll make the gray one.
So there will be a great victory MMA
and fitness shirt available on Jocko
store.com soon. I like it. I promise.
Also some women's stuff on there,
some patches and just got the patches
reordered so they should be in there,
you know, starts running better now.
It is. So, you know, take it up.
We're happy to hear that. Yeah
man. Yeah, it means a lot to us.
Some hoodies on there,
some rash guards on there for various
activities including but not limited to
Jujitsu cycling.
Um,
there was a guy on Twitter,
Instagram, I think he ran,
I think a marathon,
I think.
Nice presenting with representing big
time with the get after it. Rash Guard.
He said he did it 50% better.
50% better. There you go.
There you go. Factual proof is in
the pudding. So boom, rash guard.
Yes. Taco start.com look at that
stuff. I'm not saying buy something.
I'm saying if you want something,
get something.
Good way to support also
psychological warfare.
I'm going to explain what it is again.
It's no problem for me.
It is an album,
not a music album.
It's a spoken word album with tracks.
And these tracks are for,
they have a purpose, not just
entertainment, like, Ooh, this poetic.
It is poetic,
but that's not the purpose.
The purpose is for each track is to get
you through. When you're on the path,
on the campaign against weakness,
you'll run into these moments of weakness,
right?
Just little insert weakness,
insurgents, if you will. You know,
they show up every once in a while.
So you listen to a specific track
designated for a certain type of weakness
that'll creep in.
And the track is Jocko telling you
why you should overcome this weakness.
Why Hi doc. How as well, it's
not chuckle yelling at you.
It's just a pragmatic kind of in a waste.
The steps to take to overcome
these weaknesses. Boom.
A hundred percent a hundred
percent a hundred percent,
hundred percent. Uh, what do you
thought success rate on that one?
In my experience,
100% good way to support.
You can also get Jocko
white tea on Amazon.
It's called Jocko white tea pure.
And that's for people that
want to deadlift 8,000 pounds.
And this is another scientifically
proven, factually double blind, placebo,
placebo proven.
Somebody on or,
but I don't want to say somebody's k.
There's this guy he did lit, I dunno,
he dead lifted a bunch. Oh Yay.
Yeah. What's that? Who's that guy?
He's huge and he's worn for,
yeah. So on the Arnold Classic
and he won the Arnold Classic.
So I've been seeing a lot of that video
to are a lot of people are wanting to
test him to see if he
wasn't a Jocko white tea. Oh
No, you can't. You won't test. It
doesn't test positive. Yeah. Yeah. He's,
he only did a little bit, but the dead
lift. Yeah, he only did a little bit.
Uh, yeah. So that's Jocko
white tea. You can get that.
But that's coming in a cam by the way.
It's going to,
in starting production,
it takes a long time,
but by the summertime you'll be getting
Jocko white tea and it can like,
uh,
like one of the other energy drinks that
just fill you with sugar and get you
crazy. No, this is going to
fill you with antioxidants,
little bit of caffeine and some good
tastes. So yeah, that's common. Let's see,
what else?
Books,
speaking of books on Amazon or
wherever way the warrior kid you,
you should have that book
for all children, right?
Is there any children?
Is there any child in the world that
doesn't need way of the warrior kid? No.
Didn't think so. So get that and
speaking a way that whether your kid,
there's a new way of the warrior kid
that is outright now available for
preorder. So get it.
And one of the things that I would
like to do, everyone tells me, uh,
things like everyone should
get way of the warrior kid.
Every kid should read this book. Every
kid should read this book in high school,
Orrin in their school.
People say that to me all the
time because it's very simple,
clear lessons that everybody
should absorb and it would help.
It would have helped
me if I had that book.
everybody when they had that,
if they had that book
when they're younger.
So want to get this book
out there in two more kids.
One of the best ways to do that,
if you order way the warrior
kid to Mark's mission,
order it from different sources. Get it
from Amazon, get it from Barnes and noble.
Go to your local bookstore and say, Hey,
can you please order this book for me?
We want to get it spread out where a
bunch of different outlets are seeing the
demand for it.
That will increase the publicity that
the book receives and it will get into
more kids' hands.
That's my goal is to get more kids to
read way the word kid and to read Marx
mission, so do that. It's alive.
I'm also speaking to warrior kids.
If you want to support a warrior kid,
there's a warrior kid that's a farmer
and a businessman and he's making soap
from goat milk. Why? Cause he's getting
after it. You can order some of that.
An Irish oaks ranch.com and the motto,
because he makes,
he doesn't just make so few mixed Jocko,
so hey, he wanted to make good soap day.
I quote, I want to make good
soap. G O o d capitalized,
so he makes Jocko soap. Smells
like coconut by the way. Really?
As I like to smell of coconut.
Yeah. Is there a cool Canadian? Yes.
I didn't find it to smell like
it smells it dealt with death.
You don't think it smells like coconut?
Well maybe you have a more sensitive
why in a an old factory and the factory
sensitive situation.
Yeah,
but the motto from Taco stope stay clean.
Discipline equals freedom field manual.
Again, you know, I was traveling around I,
I signed a lot of these books and I just
traveled around when I was in Australia.
A lot of people brought it in and that
was awesome. A lot of great feedback.
One thing that's good if you have that
book and you like it and helped you get
it for someone else that you know that
that wants to get on the path or should
be on the path,
so that's pretty easy to do.
Also the audio version of that book does
not exist on audible.com it exists on
iTunes, Amazon music, Google
play, other MP, three platforms.
It's an album with tracks. Sure. That's
why we did it that way. And finally,
of course,
extreme ownership.
The new version of extreme
ownership is out look black one,
which looks cool. It's got a
little excerpt, new beginning,
and it's got an excerpt of Q and
a from this podcast in the back,
which is solid. How long is that part
of it? I don't know if they, I mean,
you know how much of that is, I think
there's eight questions. I mean in there,
you know answers, which is pretty
robust and it's fairly robust.
Yeah,
and speaking of leadership,
we have a company national on front.
We solve problems through leadership.
That's what we do. And we do it all the
time. It's me, Lafe, Babin, JP Denelle,
Dave Burke.
You
can
email
info@echelonfrontdotcomoryoucangotoourwebsiteechelonfront.com
and
of course there is the muster,
which is a leadership gathering,
a leadership seminar, a leadership
conference. What do you learn?
Their pragmatic leadership skills so
you can win. That's what you learned.
We're only doing two this year.
We're doing one in Washington DC.
You come and May 17th and 18th yeah.
Okay.
So you can come meet v Rob Jones and
then we're doing one in San Francisco
October 17th and 18th the DC one
by the way right now is already,
it's more than half sold out right now.
So these are both going to sell out
just like all the events that we've done
have sold out.
So if you want to come register as quick
as you can in extreme ownership.com
we'll see you there. And until the
muster, if you want to hang with us,
we are on the interwebs,
we are on Twitter,
we are on Instagram and
we are on patch facey ball
echo is an echo Charles.
I
am@jockowillinkandofcourserobjonesisatrobjonesjourneyandhealsohasrobjonesjourney.com
and on top of that, Rob Jones
has his own podcast. Now
he's one episode deep pool, one episode
deep ones. He's on the path. Yeah.
The podcast is called used the
weight. Yep. Oh, that's good. Yeah.
I remember miss the way, which
is you see the logo. Yeah.
So you can get that wherever MP3 are,
sorry.
Podcasts are available.
I've listened to the first episode.
You talk about getting after it and yeah,
you talk about how to get through a lot
of things, so, so it's, it's awesome.
Can I add to that? I'm kind
of an advice style. Uh,
podcasts right now are
people asking me questions?
So all those people listen to this,
know you're sending question after
question to Jocko and he just refuses to
answer you this.
He reads it and then just throws it in
the trash. No, I'm just kidding. Um,
but yeah, if anybody has questions, uh,
that they want to get answered by me,
then send them to
me@arobjonesjourneyatgmail.com
or through my website or
through social media
and I will answer them.
You just gave out your website
on this. That's awesome. Yeah.
I'll fight emailing me. Oh No,
that's my, that's my special email.
That's not like my personal,
that's my specialty mail that
I give out for stuff like this.
Hey also helps to keep it kind of
separated. So all my questions,
I can just check it on email so you don't
get to sift. Yeah. So I have to sift it.
Dang.
I got to learn that lesson too little bit.
Did I miss anything else
from your various platforms?
I mean I am working on a book too. Oh,
awesome. It's, and there's no real,
uh, you know, date to
release date or anything,
but I'm hoping it's going to
be a book about veterans, um,
and the positive
and just continuing to create that story
that I was talking about earlier about
and telling that side of the coin about
veterans that come home and are fine.
Yeah.
And I'm hoping it's going to be right now
I'm kind of making it kind of like you
ever read anything by, uh, by uh,
Plato about he had basically all of his
writing is conversations that Socrates
had.
Yeah.
So I'm hoping I'm going to make it kind
of like that where it's just basically
this a series of conversations between and
two people. And this, I just thought
this way you were saying this,
cause I think this is another important
thing about on that exact subject,
and we were talking earlier about these
two categories of like the vet comes
that comes home and he's good in the
vet that comes home and he's a little
little bit off track. Yeah.
But I would like to say,
and I know you're going to agree
with this a hundred percent,
just because you're a
little bit off track,
it doesn't mean you're going to get you,
you can't easily get back on track or the,
I've known all kinds
of veterans that they,
they were off track a little bit for a
little while and then they figure it out
and they get back on track. They find
a new mission. So you know the guys,
and that's actually fairly common in my,
in Mott from what I've seen and actually
talking to a lot of guys that that went
through Vietnam and they'd come home from
Vietnam and they were a little messed
up when they got home, you
know, and they got through it,
got over it and got it out of their
system and moved on. And again,
we've talked about,
I've talked about this before,
you know when you got
done with World War II,
you sat on a ship with a bunch of other
vets for six weeks and you debrief to
everything on a ride home and you got
that out of your system and you've got to
communicate and you got, you moved
through it mentally, Vietnam,
they didn't have that opportunity.
Vietnam, it was, oh yeah,
you're in Vietnam and then tomorrow
you're in San Francisco alone. By the way,
you're not with anybody else.
You're not with any other veterans.
D nowadays we do a pretty good
job of when you come home,
you're coming home with your unit,
you stay together,
you have people to talk to that have
the common experience. But yeah,
to the vets out there that are thinking,
oh man,
I feel like I might be one of those guys
that's not on the right track right now.
You can get back on the
right track and it's,
it's finding your new mission and
moving down that path towards towards
achieving it
and just trying everything that
you possibly can. Like for me,
it's easy to figure out what I needed to
do because there was a system in place
and it's an obvious physical injury.
But with the mental injuries,
we don't exactly know how to fix them yet,
but you just have to keep trying this.
All right. Try talking about it with the
therapist didn't work. All right. I try,
you know, hyperbolic chambers or
whatever. Try this, try that, try that.
And because just because you tried one
thing and it didn't work out doesn't mean
that you don't want to,
doesn't mean that you now are fine with,
you know,
nightmares and stuff.
You just got to keep trying everything
until everything's exhausted.
Yeah. And I'll tell you, I've,
I've, in talking to, to, uh,
Jordan Peterson,
the couple times we've had them out here
into listening to him in reading his
book,
it's become very obvious to me and it's
sort of reflective of something that
Dakota Meyer said on the podcast, which
is like, hey, there's a, your, your,
your brain, your, your mentality, your
psychology as a system and just like,
just like you have a system to move
through when you have a physical injury to
get healed or get corrected.
Well,
this is the same thing with
your psychological state.
And if that psychological state is off
a little bit, well there's things that,
there's people that know how to fix it.
If you listen to when Jordan's talking
about the way that he would bring someone
through a problem,
there's a systematic way to do that.
And I never really understood that until
I started listening to him because,
you know, when they'd send us to the
psychologist to debrief a deployment,
you know, for me it was just
sort of, uh, you know, I had the,
the negative attitude of all this,
I'm not going to tell this guy anything
cause I don't want them to think I'm
crazy and I don't want to get, you
know, put on whatever, you know, thing.
And so I just was, hey, I'm just
gonna move forward and, and,
and that's sort of my eye and I'll tell
you when I was in that was a very common
attitude was, hey, look,
I'm not going to tell this.
This psychologist does know
what I've been through,
so I'm not going to tell him anything.
That was a very common, and again,
I think for me, listening to Jordan,
because I would have been, you know,
two years ago or a year ago before
I started listening to, to, uh,
Jordan Peterson talk,
I never really saw the connection.
And then it really solidified it. When
I heard Dakota talking about it, saying,
look, this is a, I put
the two and two together.
When I heard Dakota talking about it,
like there's people just like,
if you wanted to get good at Olympic
lifting, you'd go to an Olympia.
If you try to figure that out on your,
it would take you forever and you might
get hurt. You might get hurt worse.
Whereas if you went to a real
Olympic lifting coach and said, hey,
I want to learn the clean and jerk
and the snatch, they would say, okay,
here's what we're gonna Start.
We're gonna start with a PVC pipe,
and then we're gonna
go through the motions.
They were going to get better at this,
and they're going to do high poles.
They're going to walk you
through the whole system. And,
and a psychologist will do that with
your brain. They'll say, oh, okay,
I see what you're scared of. Needles
as the example. Jordan Peterson again,
here's what we're going to do
to get you used to needles.
Well when you come back
from a traumatic event,
here's some things that we can do to,
to revisit that.
And I think the same thing that you
talked about earlier with like movies.
I think the part of my prejudice against
psychologists came from the way that
they're portrayed in movies as being like,
you know,
he's sitting on this couch and like
these weird people that you know,
and it's not, it's more
pragmatic than that. Yeah.
At least it seems that way to me.
So it's like a trainer kind of alert,
like a trainer and more like,
uh, more like a coach, right?
More like a coach or more like a Jujitsu
instructor that's saying like, Hey,
here's what you need to do here.
You get caught in this position,
here's what you need to do. The
psychologist says, Oh, you're having,
you're having bad dreams about
this. Okay, let's try these things.
And I don't know what those
things are because I don't know,
I'm not a psychologist,
but they do know,
they do know what to tell you to do and
they do know how to help you get through
those things.
And just like Jujitsu or just like
athletic training or just like Olympic
lifting,
it's going to vary for different people.
And a good psychological coach is
going to have a know how to make those
adjustments and say, Oh, you're
feeling this a little bit more.
Oh it's because you came
from this kind of family,
so this is what's going to help you.
But you came from a
different side of family,
so this is gonna help you
a little different way. So
I think those things are,
are important to think about.
And again,
I've just wanted to reemphasize the
point that just because you might be in a
Rut as a, either as a vet or just
as a human being, you know, there's,
there's every little decision you make,
you can start moving in the
right direction and moving
towards a better place in
your life and in everything that you're
doing. So just wanted to bring that out.
Echo. You got any other, anything else?
All good. Good to see you again.
Oh man, it's so awesome to be here.
Just be included among the,
the people that, uh, you guys
deem worthy of. You know,
it takes a long time to do this.
It takes a lot of preparation
and it's just for you guys to,
to take that time and spend it on
preparing to have me as a guest. It's a,
it's a huge compliment and honor,
honor for us.
Do you have any other closing thoughts?
Yeah, just want to point
out that, uh, you know,
I'm the one here in the hot seat and
I'm getting all the accolades and um,
but you know,
I didn't,
I didn't do anything that I've
accomplished without people helping me.
I like to, it's kind of
like a pyramid. Like I'm,
I'm the tip of the pyramid on like the
thing that everybody likes to see and
that's the top of the pyramid,
but there's a whole gigantic
base underneath this pyramid
that if the tip didn't
have it, then the tip would just
be a stupid rock. And so, you know,
I all the way since my recovery and I've
had supporting people and my family and
especially on this month, the
marathons thing I just did. If, if,
if my wife hadn't been there,
if Pam hadn't been there,
then it's not happening at all. I mean,
there's some things that I could say,
you know, I cut it, could have done it,
uh, but it wouldn't have been as good,
but this thing would not have
happened without her. She, I mean,
I totally gave her the reins. I, you know,
set it up and if there was any questions
she had about overall vision for what I
was trying to accomplish,
you would ask me.
But like when we had a couple hiccups
along the way and I just totally 100%
trusted her that she'd be able to take
care of it. And she did every single time.
And she, I'm sure I'm not
giving even enough credit.
I don't know. There's probably
a thousand things that she did,
I don't even know about yet. Um, but
I mean, I just, Oh, Hirsch, huge.
And then also my mom, same
thing, you know, just uh,
being willing to withstand a
month in an RV with four people,
you know, and probably putting up with
me being grumpy or whatever, you know,
in pain and stuff. And I couldn't
even imagine having, you know,
two people along with me,
the that would have a,
made it better or that I
would have trusted as much.
And then also my buddy that drove a,
and then just all the people that kept
me going that ran with me and you know,
deemed me worthy of their time and
the people that sent me messages of
encouragement that couldn't make it out.
Um,
I just owe everybody a huge debt of
gratitude and I'm going to do my best to,
to continue to keep fighting and
earn that respect and earn that,
earn their effort or in their
sacrifices as much as I can.
Awesome. Well obviously rob, it's an
honor to have you back on here again.
I look forward to whatever the hell
kind of crazy thing you do next.
I'm not sure what it's going to be,
but I'm sure it will be something awesome.
And of course thanks to everyone
for listening to this podcast.
Thanks to the service men and women
that are holding the line day and night,
day and night,
fighting against evil thanks to police,
law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
other first responders that are
always on call, always on call
to protect us here at home.
And to everyone that's listening,
I want to refer to one last journal entry
that rob wrote and something that we
talked about the last time that he
was on that was using the weight.
Okay.
Cause the way to the world
can be heavy.
The weight of the challenges and the
trials of life can drive you into the
ground
and that weight can wear
you down and break you.
But instead of letting
the weight where you down,
instead of letting the weight break you,
you can use the weight to
make yourself stronger,
to make yourself tougher,
to make yourself better.
And that is what I
recommend everyone does.
Just like rob says,
use the weight.
Now,
get out there
and get after it.
And until next time,
this is Rob Jones and echo and Jocko
out.